[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Game seven of the World Chess
Championship stayed true to form as
neither player could break down the
others defenses and the game once again
ended in a draw with three whites in the
final five games can American Fabiano
Caruana break through and take the lead
or will world champion Magnus Carlsen
continue the trend of great positions
for black in this match it's a battle of
wills as the tension mounts
day after day game 8 action live from
London starts right now
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to today in chess
world championship edition as we watch
an epic match between Fabiano Khurana
the American Challenger and our reigning
king Magnus Carlsen so far the two best
players in the world are deadlocked
three and a half points for Fabiano Kara
Juana and three and a half points for
Magnus Carlsen and today around a very
well may be the day that someone and
strikes blood I'm Jennifer Sajadi I'm
here with yasser Sara Juan and we
predicted it before the round this is
gonna be a big game yes and indeed it
looks like they're playing it opens is
ahead well I will be elated that's the
case and is it the case this is
fantastic
okay the Rasul emo was not bringing the
bacon home for Fabiano he had been
playing Bishop b5 and getting absolutely
nowhere in the previous three games with
white so this is what I have been
waiting for d4 takes Knight takes d4 now
Magnus's move up to 96 is usually the
prelude to this session Acosta Cillian
of course as g6 but II 75 the special
AKOP one of the sharpest that's what his
move order suggests that he was we've
got a session akov o the World Chess
Championship
it's Viviano finally goes for the most
testing line let's take a look at our
format well we know that we have a three
part time control it's best of 12 games
first player to six and a half points
wins the
and notre offers before blacks 30th
we've got a prize fun of over a million
euros but it's all about the title gen
and the fame that comes with it and the
schedule the schedule
well we've seen out of the next few
parents a Carolina white in three games
including the one we're playing and we
can really start to understand why he
said go time baby if the match is
deadlocked at the end there will be
tirades on November 28th and here we
have it a mainline special table oh well
actually we have a couple more moves
right after tonight b5 we did see the
move d76
now the sharpest variations all begin
with the move Bishop g5 Fabi tapped the
brakes a little bit with this positional
move 95 a move by the way that has been
favored by Magnus Carlsen himself and
they have reached this position after a
trade of knights all very theoretical
still still a very big strategic battle
taking place let's switch over to
Maurice Ashley for his take on game 8
wow this is certainly fun and this is
not the only fun event going on of
course we've been following very closely
the Women's World Championship match as
well and that one has in fact begun and
we have a result among these two great
ladies the women's world champion Jew
engine of China against Katarina like no
of Russia and Game one was a fighting
draw absolutely thrilling battle many
twists and turns in that crazy one and
so we will keep our eye on that as they
go for games in that match but if it's
tied then they will go to a tie-break
format which they've been doing so far
in this knockout event the best of two
rapid games then to blitz games ten plus
ten and if that doesn't produce a winner
then another to blitz game 5 plus 10 and
then sudden-death armageddon I'm not
sure about the five plus ten I think it
might be five plus three but we'll check
on that make sure about that then let's
go to game eight history will it be the
one well let's note that of the seven
twelve game world championships
that have been played game eight has
been the most cantankerous one in fact
set up to seven four have produced
decisive results 2006 - Paulo beat
ramnik with the black pieces fiddling
with the white pieces against uh none
uh none one with white in that same game
eight and then Kuryakin defeated Carlsen
when he over pressed with white so four
victories both white to white suplex
what's gonna happen today well if this
opening is any indication we might see
that game eight fighting spirit
belligerents come back yet again as this
is an exciting start to the round
absolutely Maurice it's just the tip
just the opening that we've been
ordering or wanting to order because as
much as we've enjoyed the hard-fought
seven game draws they've been also at
times
tepid the players haven't really got in
there and challenged one another and
this is one of the most challenging
opening Sicilian positions in the books
and the whole idea from White's point of
view is he's created a center wedge with
this pawn on d5 which also allows him on
many occasions to use his Queen side
majority for a breakthrough
now black also has his own central wedge
and he often uses his King side majority
for a breakthrough over there so it's a
battle a strategically rich battle in
store with some very nice tactical play
too so this is a opening that promises a
lot yeah I mean around eight statistics
based on just the the seven matches
might have turned out to be prescient
yeah team Bobby I'm loving the the
testing opening play sure this is just
really
I hope that you're all got your
seatbelts fastened and have the rest of
the morning and early afternoon yeah
share your day with us now the question
is is just statistically how does the
opening break down in terms of the
decisive games and which side has the
edge the upper hand and has fabbi or
Magnus made a poor choice statistically
speaking and to bring some of that those
figures to light I'm gonna really count
on my buddy Maurice Maurice what's
happening in this variation well we
should point out I mean we do like the
idea that especially coffees on the
board but without question I mean what
I'm a player
efore player was later in my career and
when I played against the Sicilian I
guess particularly against discretion
card I didn't want to go into the Bishop
g5 lines the crazy wild possibilities
that black always had these breaks with
d5 and f5 the double pawns I'd rather be
black in those positions in fact so this
treatment 95 is a way of getting away
from those main crazy unbalanced pawn
structures you look at this pawn
structure there is an imbalance and
naturally as you see that white is
established four pawns to three on this
side while black has the majority on
this side and there is because of that
there will be rich play there's no doubt
about that this stuff that's going to
happen in this game but it's not like
the crazy open line specially cause
there's those are completely while
fighting over the d5 square breaks
double pawns on f6 etc so that said this
position normally blacks black will have
to face against c4 as a treatment
sometimes c3 as a treatment this is more
mainline the move a4 is is the secondary
move that white can play for as he tries
to bind this side of the board and I
will tell you that without question this
is something that Fabi decided as they
were thinking about this Resnik oh they
must have been thinking about it a while
when they realized that Magnus might
play this reznikov when he was playing
to move Knight to c6 and they thought
what variation do we play that is
manageable that is something that we can
look at very deeply and sidestep the
majority of his preparation because his
preparation clearly is going to go for
all those mainline craziness so how do
we slice up the majority of his
preparation and then at our own wrinkle
that he's gonna have to think about at
the board so again that is it that word
that phrase that Vichy on our news about
information the who has the superior
information I forget exactly how he
termed it was that term he used yeah
Jennifer in hell it was information it's
like an information deficit but we'll
remember it right but the idea that you
are you don't know what's what the other
person is gonna play and then once you
do know what the other person was gonna
play how do you get superior information
in knowing that you can play a four like
you did here and Magnus doesn't know
which move you're gonna play and then
you could prepare very very deeply so I
suspect he'll pause here what is
actually going on as he moved after a
four no you still have the same position
actually actually no we have seen in
castles Castle there should be seven
there should be two castles castles well
quick play by the players after this
opening moves with a four it's gonna be
interesting guys it's black for choice
coming down the board with his pawns on
this side white looking to break through
on this I didn't see five etc this is
good stuff fighting chess to be sure the
most fighting probably of all the games
that white Bobby has had so far
absolutely and Maurice a quick question
for you when when that move a to a four
was played that strikes me is the
secondary move behind c2 c4 c2 c4 the
main move mm-hmm these four is
definitely the me move yeah yeah so a
for a little bit off the beaten path but
still still a standard yeah no way yeah
not yet not the main line when you play
Knight d5 at 98 but circuit because
ninety is not also is not the only move
97 is another move but 98 when you
probably the c4 is the normal but a4 is
certainly a very popular response and in
both cases you want to put your night
behind upon
rather in case of a six similar ideas
but statistically what's the score
expected score value of a four over say
support we don't get the I mean all of
it you have to drill like a generalized
statistic and it doesn't it doesn't
really help you especially the main
lines where typically the variations are
going to be very close right the results
are gonna be very very close and the
main license blacks okay and that's why
you you die verge and you probably but
still then you start getting when you
start diverging you start playing moves
that are less popular less principles
and played by players who are not the
elite of the elite of the elite much
more so as they try to avoid the main
lines and see for certainly being the
big main line but as it stands Bishop e7
which he did play has scored very well
Bishop to e2 castles and castles this is
this position has been seen quite a bit
and we have 59 games where f5 was played
immediately that's a very nice sample
size with move f5 gelfand himself has
found and has been in this position and
the move ninety seven also played many
times fifty four times and the ball of a
six also played forty four times so no
general consensus by black as to what
the correct approaches right now they've
tried different moves and have fairly
decent results as I'm looking at these
statistics even the move Bishop f5 has
been played as well and it has been
played well just a few times that
probably would not be the sample size we
want to use because it's only been
played three times but the key moves
here f5 getting the pawns rolling ninety
seven just simple development but
eventually if I will happen an a6
kicking out the knight right now
normally the night goes to 83 tries to
get this pawn storm himself on this side
having restrained black completely so
interesting double-edged battle oh yeah
it's more easy okay so to me the
difference between a five and a six is
that if you play at five
yeah I'm just white play c4 right away
white has different options here the big
move is f4 shutting down yeah there's
these pawns from going anywhere
therefore by far by far is the right
size
so my transpose anyway because if a six
you're still playing Knight a three
probably right so unless if you don't
play c4 anyway some of these lines could
end up coming to the same thing right
Oh many many times they're
transpositional I suspect that f7f five
major major move and that ninety seven
not necessarily a prerequisite to lead
with f5 but I can imagine that you play
at 597 necks or you played ninety-seven
first and then f5 next so a lot of
transpositions will probably get you
back to these types so this key moment
where he played a for both a white wants
to try to use the Queen Simon Queen side
expansion the better space he hasn't the
Queen side after trade a pawn on d5
that's right so he wants to be able to
meet a six with a more graceful move
that doesn't hold back his pawns that's
why these two ideas of a 4 and C 4 makes
sense because then when you get kicked
back you can you can slide your knight
back into c3 but I have to say I echo
maurices sentiments in that when I
played the open Sicilian knowing that
I'm attacking on the Queen side rather
than on the Kings side it felt a bit
more like a king's indian type position
to me i wasn't that comfortable with
that as well so especially Cobb was the
one opening that I gave the kibosh to I
said when they play knight c6 I can play
for should be 5 or c3 and then I'll play
against all the other Sicilians at D 6 e
6 o you'll play open Sicilian transpose
d6 I would play the open Sicilian which
was the most common way to get the
Sicilian that's right accelerated dragon
I'd play for the open Sicilian but
against 19-6 I'd often go the other way
because I your instead of being the one
attacking on the kingside you're the one
attacking on the queenside
the character of the game is very very
different as a 1.e4 player in exactly
you wanted to attack your opponent's
king you didn't want see if attacking
your car and if you played this
positional line at the special knock off
you're reacting on the Kings side and
you're pressing on the Queen side which
is not necessarily what you in
natural-born efore player wanted to do
you
and I played both of them though and I
think these positions are nonetheless
extremely rich so they're very very
little playing yes with the Bishop g5
you get a similar story though with c4
in 255 look but in both cases or 9555 in
both cases it's black who's playing for
these f5 and King side pressure right so
I find it a I find it really great
choice by Fabi in general though to play
something you were casting than the
Rasul emo and knowing that his team has
probably spent an entire recon that's
right oh absolutely
we're now at November 18 and 19th and
the map started on the 9th with c5 so
literally 10 days have passed but 5
Eastham has been able to work on a
Sicilian yeah and my guess is that we
well prior to the match that fabi's team
mainly concentrated on e5 defenses on
move one for Magnus that is they to say
that the Sicilian yes it was on the
horizon and on the radar so to speak but
not their main defense that they prepare
for I'm sure they were looking at Bobbie
class white and that's what I thought
that maybe was gonna be his third white
and instead it two-sport white but the
same principle it's kind of like you're
looking at the watch and the match is
ticking down and you're like okay right
time for someone to get something with
white exactly exactly it's hype time
depress and again I mean with each
progressive draw the red that you know
the drama and the match just keeps
ramping up and you know who's going to
blink first and to produce some
fireworks because at this point if
somebody wins a game nobody's gonna have
a chance to catch up now of course
having said that in 2016 the previous
World Championship a game 8 was decisive
Magnus lost but he won game 10 to take
it in two tiebreaks
but it's getting really close there's
only five more games to go
Magnus was pressing in so many of those
games I certainly didn't feel like it
was over once car yeah can one but this
match like Anton said on the air yet
yesterday you get more of a sense that
I'm not that it's over but it feels more
over than it did in car yeah Kim Karlsen
like if somebody wins a game because
they're playing so well and the idea of
somebody just being able to neutralize
in the final four games doesn't seem far
fast it's not outlandish no and I did
want to repeat a tweet from onigiri who
says that nonsense aside it was a good
result for favi to get to potentially
tough consecutive black games behind him
time to ask the boys if there's finally
any news in the Rasul emo apparently the
boys no thankfully thankfully and by the
way in this theoretically awkward
position where it seems to me that both
f7 f5 and knight on b8 to d7 as Maresa
explained have been equally played
Magnus did shoes for the move f7 f5 at
once and instead of playing f2 F for
trying to
fix the center is what I want to say
there we saw the move c2 c4 expanding on
the Queen side by Fabiana what I mean by
the by fixing the center you see that
these pawns on e5 and f5
black has ideas like Knight to d7 b v e4
Knight to e5 + f5 f4 with a very
aggressive attack on the King side so
it's very often in White's interest to
try to blockade or fix the pawns in the
center in the Kings side with a move
like f4 e for Bishop e3 this would
really play very very nicely into
White's hands also now that this knight
on b5 has not yet been kicked backwards
this early e5 e 4 is very helpful
because now the knight could swing back
to the central square d4 eyeballing the
e6 as well as f5 pawn so F 2 F 4 we
understand why that move was popular but
that was not a B's choice he did go for
c4 over to you Maurice did he go for c4
Bishop d2 yeah here we see the live word
up in the snow it was it wasn't f5
Bishop d2 is Bishop d2 at 585 isn't it
black to move now great Bishop d2 was
played first then at 5 and then a 5
bye-bye-bye Fabi
it is now blacks turn everybody to so
this is important very important to note
and why so let's just drill deep a
little bit more into this position the
move Knight d7 we mentioned there are a
couple of other moves f5 a 697 is also
one of the main moves this move Knight
d7 was played by Gelfand I mentioned
that name because Gelfand played his
World Championship match against unknown
and in that match they also went into
Rhossili Moser if you remember that's
very cleanly so that's something that
everyone knew that that's what Gelfand
did so in 2012 Nakamura had to play
against Gelfand and he got a stretch
Nicole and so he decided to also avoid
the mainlines against get fun because he
didn't want Seagal class preparation
well it turns out that as he avoided he
played exactly this way and in this
position he played King to H 1 delaying
a move preparing to play the move f4
if f5 was played the game went F 5 F for
a 6 9 83 and then he takes f4 taking in
a completely different direction
eventually putting a knight on d4 on e5
but in fact I'd like to go down the
moves just a little bit because after
Bishop f4 95 Queen d2 was played in this
position and then Bishop D set I'm
jumping ahead a little bit let me just
get that right yes Queen d2 and then
Bishop d7 that's right Queen B 4 and
rook b8 not giving white any targets at
all on this side guarding the b-pawn and
then he prepared this maneuver which is
when I get to a 5 Queen b3 Knight g6 and
after the bishop drop back b6 creating
this pawn structure was very difficult
for white to get anything on this side
you notice the pawns are very much
blockaded so white just doesn't have any
energy on that side although he does
have squares to work with but this
Bishop is guarding all the business
squares so he used this position he
ended up winning the game it was a sharp
game that you look at the position you
can tell it's a sharp position but this
is how it proceeded white didn't get the
play he wanted on the Queen side that
aggression so later if we switch to
another game of import it's a game
between Oparin and Gelfand Grandmaster
Paran played this way Bishop d2 by the
way my database only found four games in
the line Bishop d2 4 out of all those
games in a position and Bishop d2 played
twice by a part against gun fun want to
draw one a win against Gelfand we're
talking about and we are updating to
this year to 2017 it was a rapid game
nevertheless a6 was played immediately
in that game very important to note a 6
was the move point and he tried did he
to blockade that side but after Knight
c4 b6
F for very aggressive Bishop a 693
Bishop d7 and now Bishop to c3
initiating an attack in this direction
he went on to win a very nice game did
open against Gail fun who's a specialist
in the lining you noticed that f5 is a
bit of a problem trying to play because
I capture and then a capture on that
square the or the move order that he
used also the idea of trading off light
square bishop would certainly favor
white in this position so this is the
nuance that Bobby went down dug into
when to look for I said you know what
let's avoid all the main stuff if he
plays like this let's play this way but
let's make sure we get our expansion on
the Queen side and now we're current
with this position bishop to eat Bishop
e2 castles 97 Bishop to d2 and now after
f5 this move
a5 not giving black any chance
whatsoever to fully blockade this side
and that's an important distinction in
this position in that he an employee f4
to stop black's expansion here he
quickly played a 5 that means we are
fully in fabiana's preparation fully
because all these moves are very natural
this plan is new and Carlsen sitting
there having seen preparation from game
two that he ducked from game 6 our game
7 was a game game seven that he ducked
as well right his second white in a row
game seven that he does he's now seen
Fabi again for our new preparation what
happens now I can't really duck it
because it's white doing it to him he
has to look at this position of fresh
this is certainly a challenging move the
move a5 Wow
ok Thank You Maurice I'm still trying to
get my mind around it myself
I remember I think it was from the Cinco
Cup where it was a game of Shaq
manmadharao's where he had such
structure remember he went g7 g6 at a
certain moment because he didn't know
really what to do and then he followed
it up later with G 65 I'm still trying
to understand why black has delayed a 6
booting the night back to a three and
can Magnus take advantage of the fact
that he hasn't included the move a six
so it's it's a little bit awkward for me
so I I'm really thinking that there's
well there's yeah Knight f6 is certainly
a move I didn't want to interfere with
my bishop coming to g5 or Bishop f6 so I
was thinking more like Knight c5 so the
idea here is of course I'm I bought this
great before 94 and I'd be very happy to
eliminate the dark square bishop if you
would allow it on the other hand I'm
asking white are you really going to
expand with c4 and maybe on a good day
for example c4 Bishop d7 maybe I'm
thinking about capturing this night but
instead we have a move a six the medium
okay so and at any moment the last three
or four moves
Magnus could have played a six at his
whim and forced the knight back to a3
but he could have only done but the
point is with this is you do it and then
you gar you blockade that side as we saw
Gelfand doing this is important to note
is that after a six night a3 you follow
it up with a 5 a 5 and you don't have to
worry about this a pawn going down the
board white a successfully place the
pawn on e5 so now b6 is weak for a long
term that's something that at least
white pretends he wants in these
positions is to get this weakness on v6
and try to use it so from this position
we have I'm a little bit ahead o the
move Knight f6 by the way you've got to
think about this move Bishop to e3
because the a pawn hangs and suddenly if
you move it then Bishop to b6 shows up
and again that weakness of the be 6
squared plays a role so I'm gonna go
back a couple of moves again
also your move after a 5 if you play
Knight c5 e for 90-94 Bishop II 1 and
again the threat is f3 your knight has
no
future is gonna be chased over to this
side of the board maybe they have six
where it could have gone to in one move
what's your argument that you delet you
liked my playing before with tempo
because f3 is coming now and so that's
why Magnus in this position and to
figure out exactly what to do or what
what should he do but he played the move
a six which Bobby probably looked at and
thought was not a good idea in this kind
of position his knight now has a path to
b6 if this Knight moves off of the
square so this is a very challenging
formation y can say he successfully done
what he wanted in fact black just
acquiesced to the controller to be six
squared will he himself play something
like b6 or b5 and force a capture as we
seen in many Sicilians and try for a
counter play on that side as well
wise pawns are gonna go down the board
so that's quite a dangerous idea but to
your to whites eyes he's been successful
in getting what he wants out of this
opening this weakness on this side and
he is now played 983 on the board
expect to see more expansion on the
Queen side by white with this button on
a5 playing a restrictive role as
expected he's been preparing for this
for ten days yeah well well prepared who
do you like I mean obviously from a
preparation point of view knowing that
Fabi is in his crap and magnets a
surprise I love Bobby but in terms of
the position itself I I'm confused I'm
not sure who I like who do you like I
like white and the reason why is unlike
yourself who or 1.e4 player I'm an
English opening player but I also took
up d4 and I like the white side of the
King's Indian so of course you like that
I always carry or brought Fisher back
from the dead they would say give me
black right so so it's a stylistic
matchup and for myself I always like
playing on my opponent's weak squares
and right now we're gonna see beasts of
a b6 square being hit very hard by fabbi
the question that I would have had for
Maurice is it's quite clear that fabbi
wants to stick his bike on the c4 and if
there's only one issue that white has in
the position it
the pawn on g7 on d5 army doesn't have
completely full or adequate protection
so for example Knight f6 hits the pawn
and I don't think you can play Knight c4
I think I can just take that pawn on d5
and be a happy camper and if after
Knight f6 I'm assuming white doesn't
want to play the move c4 because then
well now the night on a threes off side
and it's not quickly getting to the b6
were so the question I would have for
you Maurice is after the move Knight f6
how does white juggle the things that he
wants he wants his Knight to c4 but he
doesn't want to give up his d5 pawn
either oh there should be three here
just you can take it still is it a
hundred percent probably it's not it is
two pawns after all right I mean I could
I could even sacrifice an exchange if I
didn't correct I don't think we need
I don't think Bishop III is what you
wanted to allow so Knight f6 maybe the
bishop has to just drop back and play
possum for a moment or two before you
get to put your knight on on b6 Bishop
b4 is another idea which is a little
unusual but that's really specifically
trying to get the knight to b6 here that
is certainly trying to get the knight to
specifically like the oh that's mainly
the plank was a bit urban in the way of
the pawns from that Square this move Wow
well it's funny because normally the
bishops not on before it's not like III
or anyone I'm not but here you you're
gonna get hit by Knight see for you oh
yes oh yes I have to know I'm wondering
if if I should play C direction of like
Queen Queen d2
it's it's a double-edged position but
the only question I has was was Knight
f6 the most challenging to white setup
what's the move eg for WoW going with
that move so that really basically you
know Telegraph's I'm playing for be five
and you can have the be six square so
let's see
efore 94 now well be be careful because
f4 thingamajiggy that you got to look
out for always always I mean this
position just got called the jig's
Bishop g4 might be met by have three I
remember numerous games as a Kings
Indian defense player where white very
often plays this move rook a3 and it's
as beautiful idea it's not so much as a
rover head in terms of an attacking
setup but much more of a defensive one
it's basically saying that ideas of f3
and III my rook on the 3rd rank is going
to patrol this ring and make it very
difficult for the attack to break
through wow this is really double-edged
stuff great great start to this round 84
sorry I would we're gonna have reader in
the game we're gonna have Grandmaster
Peter let go one of the top GM's
in the world and the World Chess
Champion challenger he's gonna be on the
show I'm dressed the golf genius as well
exactly
yes indeed so quite fortunate for us to
have him on and we'll have some great
guests on coming up and later shows as
well some big names that you will
recognize he's a World Championship not
Titleist and that's all I'll say for now
you don't have to watch the show to find
out what this position
guys this was just wild Eve 494 F
for the engine against Bishop e4 Knight
f6 and queen d4 I'm giving you one line
f3 sacrificing the pawn and after GF 3 9
h5 just going for it
you've got that side take as much as you
want but suddenly black is looking to
put a 9 on f4 Bishop on f6 just come
down as fast as possible get the Queen
in the mix what's going on here no one
knows the engines are giving almost
triple zeros ok slight edge to white
actually in this position but chaos
reigns in a position like this one who
will fight this battle better I mean
that's really what it's going to come
down to because in an equal position
it's gonna be do you feel miss the right
way and mistakes are absolutely going to
be punished
so it's came eight I don't know what it
is about game eight in these matches but
we've got it now and this is the
position indeed after the movie four
you've got to love it the players are
finally going for it this is the kind of
chess we wanted to see them play from
the very beginning it's been a long wait
but it's been a very worthwhile way
furry's that night c4 f4 I gotta tell
you I don't think I would find the move
Bishop before an attractive move first
of all my bishop looks a little bit
funky yeah I definitely for what's a
more normal move yeah yeah well
absolutely I say good night on a3 is out
of the game night c4 is basically the
perfect square because it does attack d6
and it does protect the e5 square so
Knight c4 is an automatic after f4 which
isn't completely an automatic for me I
would play the move rook a3 I would just
say a look
I'm here to refute f2 f3 magnets are
playing are are intuitive and therefore
it's probably is probably still in his
crack so even if Bishop e4 is a little
weird-looking if you looked at it with
sesay and top computer engine speed of
top computer engineers played by Magnus
not so not at yeah I wasn't completely
clear to me this sorry five computer
engines yeah
and deep learning the creator of
deepmind demis hassabis plead 1.e4 for
Fabiano Khurana in the opening in the
opening so he was the he was the
official who started off the game
they've had celebrities I saw the great
minds every day I think a top British
junior yeah but yeah deep mind of course
created the alpha zero program who all
had us just mystified by some of its
extraordinary play and if you want to
learn more about Dennis Hasset if
there's a great documentary about his go
program which also touches on chess as
well called alpha-gal right a brilliant
guy I mean just incredible what they've
done there that said the fact that he's
playing 1.e4 means that it must be the
best move yeah that's my test of course
the person who makes the first move they
they have to have to play with the
player tells them right but I can't
remember if alpha zero like the
authority for a better to you think of
more or less I didn't see the drawn
games I saw the decisive games it seemed
like it was favoring d4 yeah I think
sometimes right after a few million
games that's late again so that's why
this has this like stream bad look on
his face that what a play d4 Hey now
this after the move Knight e5 I think a
lot of amateurs would ask themselves a
very salient question should I capture
that knight on e5 exactly good double up
my opponents pawns now here's where why
we've got ourselves so excited at the
start of play because of these
majorities we love these majorities look
at blacks a huge kingside central
majority is literally five versus three
over here and then from whites point of
the view these one two three four pawns
versus these two pawns so it's you know
like oh you know you go for the races
here with
b4 c5 but black isn't without his own
counter with I'd argue that my race is
better than yours I got a juicy King at
the finish line with my wire plus he
already had a plan a very clear plan in
mind he played a Knight b6 and exactly
to be a plate f4 and that blunts the
pawns from going down the board now that
pawn on f5 is sitting there unable to
make any energy it are you almost forced
to capture by the way absolutely on a3
because there's no question your pawns
will go nowhere if you just back up and
he gets to play Bishop e3 and smile so
f4 is it's almost compels he takes on f3
followed by Bishop takes f3 and then we
have that position where Wyatt can say
he's gotten his Knight to the b6 square
exactly yeah big Bobby looks like he's
still in his prep but he's throwing out
his moves no question that his prep here
had to have been deeper than Magnus is
prep in this was in this position
because Bobby got to pick which line he
was going to play while Magnus had to do
deep deep prep on all the lines that's
right of the specialty cough so he
couldn't go he couldn't drill super deep
into every single position at some point
you have to say you know what this is
okay I can play this this is okay I get
the ideas no doubt Bobby and his seconds
not only did they show him the lines but
they played several blitz games in the
line as well training games let's see
what you how you feel this position
getting in your fingertips he might have
played 20 30 games in this line to get
the different nuances out just to get a
competitive feel that's a normal
strategy that top players do everybody
should do it in fact don't just study
the opening lines and try to memorize
this is the move this is the move this
is the move best person is a partner or
a computer a best a human partner
obviously best is both so just practice
and say let me get this position in my
fingertips see what it feels like before
I sit at the board and have to play it
especially in the World Championship
match so probably playing very quickly
at 4 on the board he's seen this
position before
he's playing it lightning-fast and
Magnus will have to say okay when am I
going to get out of this guy's
preparation because he clearly looks
very confident that he knows what's
going on that's right he's playing
instantly and this is something that
Fabi sometimes does when he's in prep he
doesn't make any bluffing attempts where
he's saying like oh maybe I know it
maybe I don't because there's another
way to go about it just play instantly
it puts a lot of pressure on your
opponent well it also sends a very clear
message that look I prepared this I know
what I'm doing and I've got I've got my
plan already formatted how about you and
and as we've seen that sometimes that
feeling can sometimes cause Magnus to
play substandard news which when he's
playing white it's okay press conference
maybe it was a bit soft but wait it's
okay right right he's still made a
comfortable draw in fact as Fabi said in
the press conference
it was it was still him who have to find
good moves but do that with black and I
say no idea no having said that how good
is whites position eight of three I'm
thinking purged has occurred I I'm
thinking I'm passant as absolutely force
but thank goodness is that rule exists
yes exactly and now okay so why does
definitely got his Knight firmly us
Const on the queenside this Knight of b6
is excellent I don't like this Bishop on
c8 I would love to have the Bishop on f5
which means I have to move the pawn for
to f4 which means in order to do that
I've also got to think about g5 but
let's start with the straightforward f4
and just a question how did how do you
like it do you like to play this
position Jen looks really good but I do
read I am worried about the security at
that part of that floor as you mentioned
if the bishop moves for instance I guess
what I guess I played Bishop before you
have Bishop g4 g4 and suddenly a lot of
your
issues are solved because you get that
[ __ ] about and bottle up with f3 yeah
once you get f3 you start to worry that
White King is I mean we're just excited
because Bobby's the one it's such a
double-edged said he's the one with the
information advantage yeah the one who
knew he was gonna get in and studying it
not just the last couple days but
perhaps the whole week exactly and so
that that's a big advantage in terms of
psychology and time but in terms of the
position I'm not ready to give white a
huge edge yeah I meet me too because
again I'm looking at this knight on e5
and from blacks point of view a lot of
his moves dude it strikes me strike me
is quite natural g5 Bishop f5 and how do
you play against rook a for right now
not the first move that came to my mind
there look 284 so you attack the pawn so
I'll defend the pawn go baby
Bishop c3 Bishop to c3 so I'm wondering
if you're gonna take or not okay Bishop
the F fine
finally see this night on b6 really
really cramps blacks Queen site but if
the Queen side pieces all escape to
develop square the knight actually looks
like then the bishop
efore yes the corner taking a selfie
uh-huh
just according exact can we go back to
g4 like we did before I guess it's not
as quite as appealing butyl game it's my
time but still but again I mean Queen
mocha Queen d2 yeah before we were
playing f3 but I guess in that situation
you had like Bishop e5 and then take on
well blacks pieces are finding good
squares - I mean White's pieces all have
good squares the idea of f3 isn't going
anywhere right you you just want to play
you know Queenie
and keep up the momentum of getting your
pieces to good squares that is a nice
majority that that three pawn versus two
pawn and you know if you put this pawn
on c5 very very fast
I'll take white but I think this is a
three-edged of d4 3-3-3 result game yeah
say that again
[Laughter]
[Music]
perpetual in the middle game a win for
white in the middle game a win for black
in the middle game or all the three
things in the endgame I'll tell you what
I mean you know all of these top
grandmasters you talk about polarized
American politics polarized chess
grandmasters I think a lot of special
akov players would make an argument why
they like black and I think a lot of
white players would make an argument why
they would like wait archit plays and
everybody knew right and we'd have
trouble with both colors everybody in
the world against alpha zero colors by
the way it didn't it started off playing
the Sicilians if I remember correctly
but it does kind of dropped off right
yeah yeah so I would have cringed
watching the first couple moves in this
game before yeah exactly so I'm saying
that okay
kudos to kudos to fabbi for his
preparation
he's definitely kind of an edge on the
clock and he's probably very familiar
with the position but after this takes
takes I don't know if we should begin
with g 5 or f 4 as we started out and oh
and or Bishop f6 but I still haven't
seen a position where I say oh I really
think this is a big advantage for fabbi
and this preparation looks terrific
jury's still out for me well yeah and by
the way I was totally overstating the
alpha zero thing
because it prefers d4 and double King
pawn doesn't mean that it does it thinks
it's a massive difference no we're
talking about incremental difference
exactly the shades yeah I mean the
reason it's we would be crushing human
players would be because of other
reasons yeah its tactical awareness it's
just it's it's extraordinary they gifted
in terms of position this type of
position it would be particularly
excelling in because this is very
explosive and a lot of creative ideas
can end up being key and very very
forcing lines now Maurice is over there
just looking at the supercomputer of
sesay and how Maurice share with us for
your your research well SSA is giving
this position as essentially equal very
slight edge to white in this position
which black will take because that's
basically what the initial assessment is
supposed to be in the opening itself
because white has the first move it's
giving f4 as the key move with rook a4
but not g5 but Bishop to g5 as a primary
move there although g5 when I'm looking
at this with a normal engine right which
which is still 3200 f4 rook a 4G 5 in
the line that you talked about doesn't
seem like that bad or move a little bit
more loosening to be sure but certainly
thematic Bishop to g5 is given as a very
solid move here for black keeping the
position together and again the issue of
exactly how does what does white get his
pawns going down the board with effect
right that is the question we have right
now
exactly how does that work and how does
Bobby plan to execute that because here
black may not be going anywhere but
neither is white per se he does have the
opportunity to just try to push and
maybe even sacrifice which c5 that
happens sometimes but you got to do all
that timing it out really really well
here it does look like he can you can go
for it it looks like a shark just
extremely as you mentioned you has an
extraordinarily sharp position and
that's it and now we've got to figure
out some plans for both sides White's
plan is very clear here but I spread I'm
not so sure you mentioned bringing the
bishop out and well you like to pawn me
on g5 I light upon that makes the pool
makes the plan very clear disposition
less so with the bishop sitting on g5
we'd have to find out if this actually
gives natural play would be something
that magnets would do given that you
have to find a way to play this position
you could also drop the bishop back and
then play for g5 but you have to argue
why the bishop is better here than it is
on the square
exactly well again as a King's Indian
Kirk rat defense player I like my fiance
doe Bishop so that's why I like to play
g5 and Bishop f6 I think a lot of King's
Indian players seems which would feel
the same way it's kind of ironic though
that after a move like f4 rook a for the
computers like to post their bishop
behind the pawn like this Bishop g5 I
mean a lot of human players would just
sit there so whoa isn't my bishop
you know I'm self-contained myself I've
trapped
I've been snared my bishop behind the
pawn whereas if I put my pawn on g5 and
my bishop on f6 it may be going places I
see this as a very exciting game in
store for us back over to you Maurice
please yes I was I woke up this morning
pretty early and I was looking online at
different things you know as we all do
looking at social media yeah then got
one post I talked about art that argue
that these twelve game matches make for
boring chess twelve games people are
being very careful they don't want to
fight too hard they're testing each
other out one game one decisive games
game make such a big deal that they're
scared to play wow it's a it's a very
logical argument but don't let logic get
in the way of facts let's take a look at
the history of 12 game matches beginning
with chronic to Apollo in 2006 well
that's what game match certainly was not
careful dull boring at all there were
six decisive games okay admittedly one
was a forfeit game that toilet gate
argument but six the decisive games in
that match then if we go to the very
next match crown they come on we see for
decisive games
then to announce Apollo of five decisive
games I needed to win the last game in
order to win the match a 12 game as a
matter of fact they started with body
blows right away out the gate and by in
that kramnik won the very first one he
won the first two games in that match as
well then we see a little tapering off
on on vs. gelfand were only two decisive
games they needed rapid chance to decide
it we run on one one of those four games
then anon Carlson was just pure
domination three games one he need him
indeed a 12 game in order to decide that
match then for decisive games in Carlson
and on again early wins appearing in
games two and three if memory serves
correct in that match and then it was
Carlson Kuryakin where Carlson just had
car yakin by the throat and couldn't
seal the deal because sorry I can't
defended so well and then Carlson lost
the game eight pushing too hard
and then finally had to win a game and
then they went to rapid where Carlson
one two so these games have these
matches have been quite cantankerous as
i wearn I'd be using but it shows the
sort of recency bias that people have
when they see well all these drawers
that must be a reason and those who
prefer the longer matches will point to
the 12 game match as the flaw well that
has simply not been the case
historically yeah I think you could
argue a lot of people have this feeling
that on happens to disagree with that
magnets is such an overwhelming favorite
in the tie breaks and you he might be
trying to play four draws or like not
take us not play four draws that's an
exaggeration but not take as many risks
like for instance we should be to is
you're already thinking maybe I can just
get to the the tiebreak I don't know if
that's true or not maybe it'll be turn
in the last couple of games but you can
just give the exact contrary argument
for Fabi then you can say maybe he wants
to take a risk to avoid that I mean he
doesn't think he's a I'm sure he doesn't
think he's a massive underdog but he'd
rather win a classical game of course so
I think that it's just kind of these
things it's a duality right like if what
if it's true that one player doesn't
want it to happen then that almost by
definition means the other player once
it happened yeah
I'm still struck by
something that you had said yesterday
and first of all thank you for setting
the historical record straight Maurice
but taking a look at this match and the
very very previous match you were saying
Jennifer how incredibly accurate the
players play has been and their accuracy
is going to just get better and better
in the future
so I mean are the number of draws going
to be so high and we were talking about
the World Championships like Magnus
Carlsen 2016 that played 12 games in one
one yay lost one so far seven games
drawn right so I've there's 19 classical
recent 19 classical games that Magnus is
play ds-11 exactly the dominating
performance that we've come to expect
out of our world champion remember
though he did dominate his two matches
against Iran and he had three wins
though so fair being fair to him it's
not it's his opponents have been getting
better and better that's right I've sort
of figured him out a little bit the fear
factor is not there anymore particularly
against players who are his exact same
age or even younger is fabbi as is Fabi
so the older players you know it's kind
of a passing of the torch a generation
who gets a little bit weaker maybe
they're not as in their prime anymore
but you got these guys who are hungry
they see him and they say oh no we want
a piece of you we don't have the same
fear as as the others when you were just
blasting through and wiping away a
generation almost I mean we had guys
like to pawn off Kramnik Anton Gelfand
who were ruling the roost at the top and
then the young guns showed up and said
well you know we've seen Carlsen beat
all you you know you guys we're gonna
try to get a piece of that action right
and now are we gonna fight him too and
we're seeing them fight him well yes so
that has certainly changed historically
and we have a move g5 yeah that's I was
teasing Rex Sinquefield the other day
are saying in a Rex you know we're
commentators you want us to make chicken
salad you got to give us some chicken
you know
and I don't know this game is really
giving us all kinds of things to talk
about I love this I want a middle game
with Queens and I want double edge I
call yesterday was like the first middle
game we have the Queen so that quickly
became a queen full and game right g5
okay now
cantankerous contentious let's on this
one I like belligerent wild right now
but I will tell you the computers hate
g5 okay sexy things bad move so bad that
he's almost lost the pawn all right not
an inaccuracy but a mistake Wow first no
and there's no and there's no losing a
partner on the board there's no sequence
that loses the pawn so I think that
saying I can win upon by force I just
don't like the move just hates g5 which
is incredible it's giving a 1.33
advantage to white in this position and
and whites loose is c4 why it's not
winning any material why just continuing
to carry out this plan of this Queen
side demonstration with c4 and Bishop c3
I'm just looking at the moves
c4 Bishop f6 and the Bishop c3 Knight d7
so I mean this doubt this is set by the
way stockfish is saying it's fine for
blacks stop overstating the case so you
makes you kind of curious what alpha
zero would say but as this game heats up
you're gonna go to a quick break because
we're getting set up with our special
guest Grand Master and World
Championship Challenger in 2004 Peter
let go and approach the console is -
well we're gonna wonder if he art you
would get in there and
I had an especially cop to the death
we're also going to leave you with the
top players in the US and their thoughts
or actually I think top players
internationally and what they think
about this map
Fabiano has ability to morph because
he's always learning new things so I
think I wouldn't you know be just to him
if I would say that his chances are less
than 45% I definitely hope you'll hold
in this match he the tremendous player
and I like a massage it's a person too
despite despite him wishing wishing me
to do better in all my tournaments and I
think it's really hard to do not call
Magnus a favorite no matter how much you
love America or whatever else I'd be on
represents so I think I have to give him
30 percent chance well it's it's
probably well it's hard to say the
closest match because Korea can already
brought him to a tie-break but let's say
this match I expect to be very
competitive but also I think the games
will be very hard-fought and open
karyakin
and to some degree I we tried a a more
solid approach not allowing Magnus a lot
of space that was kind of the idea we
had but I think Fabiana will take it to
much harder and it's nice that the two
of them are the closest interacting that
Magnus will have faced no match I feel
the Fabiano has to one of the classical
if it goes to wrap it I think that
Magnus is probably 95% or better to win
in the rapid
it's simply based on the historical fact
that Magnus pretty much never loses a
tiebreaker and even the tiebreaker he
played against Sergei in the last World
Championship he he really dominated that
and I think I would consider surgery to
be a vastly superior rapid and blitz
player to Fabiano's so Fabiano has won
in classical and I think it's gonna be
very close much I would rate Magnus is a
very slight favorite like 55 or 60
percent favorites if they were going to
play hundred matches
I would definitely favor Magnus it
someone March and I think that Fabiana
will rise to the challenge and give - as
hard a time as he can possibly get
Carson of course is still number one in
the world is best chess player in the
world forward will be Magnus but I hope
Quran will be
I hope just what will change something
some new world champion will come I hope
her on a whirlwind I think his models
chance is better because he is still
number one and he's very strong he's
very dangerous opponent for Mars and
that he if he is able to come to the
March like in his top shape then I'm
pretty sure it will be very close much
it is clear from the last tournaments
that he he's keeping his high level this
form yeah I think
it will be very very close much very
interesting fish
I think it's 45% for Quran and 55 for
Mongols but at the same time I wish
Fabiana will win because we all need
some change the changes and we are all
very tired of mongoose and if there will
be some changes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to today in chess
world championship edition as we see
Fabiano carolina has prepared this
opening yes in fact on the break I
checked and it turns out that after 18
moves bobby had more time on the clock
and he started with oh my god so it's
really played virtually instantly in the
30-second bonus has added time that's
right so and putting the pressure on
Magnus if you do play the move of c4 and
g5 we left it we saw the move c4 then we
saw the move f4 so very natural play by
both players and it seems like this is
the first time so far in the game that
Fabi is sneaking into a thing sinking
into a think rather um but that's a
perfect time to bring on our special
guests who we are so lucky to have today
we've got one of the top grab bastards
in the world former World Championship
Challenger and especially qov with
specialist you have a Peter like oh
thank you for joining us so much yeah
hello everybody good morning Peter from
Hungary what do you think about today's
opening well I think it's fascinating
that's what we are all waiting for so
far we have seen all the Rasta limos
against this version ago in fact really
this whole match from the blacks tonight
looks like some vintage like homage
because I used to play I used to play
this vestnik or exclusively and
basically thanks to this rationale I
became the war championship Challenger I
qualified myself in Dortmund 2002 thanks
to winning a lot of games with black in
the sveshnikov and I faced also a lot of
anticipation curves so I was really very
interested to see how the match develops
and how Fabiano will try to change how
he will try to shift since he didn't
really achieve anything with Rasta limos
and today we finally see him going for
the sveshnikov and going for the night
default line which I have been actually
using with white in 2002 exactly at the
moment when I was playing the sveshnikov
I also was playing it from the white
side this
also give some hint that special players
do think that this 95 option is a really
serious one why did you choose it over
the lines of 55 yourself
was it stylistic or you just thought it
was the best move no the point is that
usually the sveshnikov players like to
play a certain type of positions and
after Bishop g5 and take econ f6 you
always kind of get the standard
sveshnikov but by playing Knight before
you change the pawn structure of the of
the position and the position very much
resembles some note of structures and
this is already kind of psychological
okay modules kiss of course he plays all
kinds of opening so it shouldn't really
come as a surprise to him to change the
structure but still when you are ready
to you are going for the sveshnikov you
kind of want to play smash legal
structures so it's it's kind of
psychological and I think from Fabiano's
case it was like a very logical choice
if he is willing to enter this reznikov
then he doesn't know in the main lines
which lines Mongols gonna choose and
this is always something that you really
worried during the World Championship
match because you know that your
opponent definitely is fully armed in
his setup and you still don't know which
setup it is but with Knight d5 you
basically force the game into your
territory and this is one of the things
that the team members really like
because then they can devote their time
and try to find some specific idea where
we gonna try to surprise Magnus and not
waiting that he gonna surprises again
brilliant Peter now when you say that
you mean that when in the Bishop c5 line
there's a couple branches that black
issues like playing f5 or Bishop e6
exactly I mean f5 and Bishop g7 those
are the two completely different type of
positions and even other later inside
there are a lot of options while here
white limits black choice after 95-96 d5
exd5 98 is kind of almost exclusively
played and Fabiano chose this position
away with a four I think c4 used to be
much more the the main move
but I know and I do remember that
somebody brought to my attention already
in 99 or 2000 that you know if you play
this vegetable you have to watch out for
this a poor line because the whole idea
is that you don't push c4 yet and this
case the white knight has the positive
through SDC for to get to b6 like it
happen in the game well if you put the
pawn on c4 black plays a6 you have to
defeat to c3 with the night and you kind
of never really can use this basic
square so basically I think the move and
Bishop d2 was was kind of a key move on
move 12 it looks like a half harmless
move looks like white is doing nothing
by Bishop d2 but in fact Clippers this
whole a5 line if I've idea that after a6
you can nail it with your knight to HD
because the phone is not hanging on a
fan this is the kind of crucial and the
way things are going it's it leaves
definitely very very dynamic position
with lot of chances for both sides but
usually I think this is the territory
which suit now white because white is
still kind of more into his preparation
that's right it looks like Bobby's
played all of his moves almost instantly
until this moment after the move f4 it
looks like Bobby's thinking for the
first time in the game oh he's on the
board ah he's played Bishop to e3 so he
must still be in in his preparation
Peter beyond this game what do you think
of the match so far has it surprised you
in any way well I mean I knew from my
own experience that the first game is
very special I mean the first game
especially if you get the white pieces
you kind of feel yourself obliged to
show the whole board that as a
challenger you you are ready to face the
world champion and I think Magnus very
much was trying to to use the same
moment like Kramnik used against me
because he really challenged Fabiano in
the first game and definitely Fabiana
was kind of into a fight he wanted to
show that yeah
doesn't matter if it's your preparation
I gonna play principal and I'm ready to
enter and I going to challenge you but
he'll run into some really deep
preparation and he was finally very
lucky to escape after that however he
was able to show some very good
preparation with the black side and once
you feel yourself completely secure that
nothing is happening to you when you are
safe when you are playing black you feel
yourself see if then there is not so
much pressure when you are playing white
and and then you kind of feel like okay
I have the freedom of light to test my
opponent in different lines try to see
how he reacts
maybe I gonna try to find a weak spot or
find something very you open and we feel
uncomfortable finally it seemed like
that also me lost all emo is not not the
right territory for that because the
fight is quite limited now there are not
so many options to totally surprise and
once it was clear that Magnus has his
setups and those setups are worked out
it was quite logical that you have to
move on and it's also psychological that
viana exactly at the halftime so it
feels like nice the right time to to
start a new clash a new front this is
also what what kramnik did if you
remember back to my game my match then
the first games versa I was planning to
play the marshal so we have seen a lot
of aunty Marshalls and finally when the
second half of the match started then he
finally was ready to end enter the
marshal because he did not really expect
from me before the match that I gonna
play the marshal so he needed time to
adjust and once he went for this very
critical line which I have finally won
in some fairytale circumstances I
nevertheless stop playing the marshal
for the entire match it had such an
effect definitely of course now with new
computer technologies you don't really
happen to the opening that you came up
with but those days in 2004 it was
kind of clear that if he is ready to
enter the Marshall and he's already
probably spending so much time with the
England of coaches that item just to
leave it and and move on now we will see
what will happen in in this year because
the position is a fascinating one
I also saw that Magnus okay basically
did not really have a choice
I mean when you are faced with a new
concept you kind of automatically feel
like it would be nice to find a solid
set up where you can just play without
any big concessions however here he if
black is not going for the principled
moves like f5 and E 4 and 95 and try to
get a counter play on the kingside then
you are just risking to be tortured on
the on the queenside and if you are not
in time you might just lose the game so
basically this pressive intentions from
black side are the way to create enough
dynamics to counterbalance the the
problem that you are facing on the
queenside
now we are seeing some some position
where time is a huge factor it's clear
that if one gets two extra tempos and
get some B 4 C 5 in then blacks position
will just collapse so I guess black is
trying some Bishop f6 Bishop f5
connected with g4 and encounter play on
the King side so it's it's very easy to
explain what is happening strategically
but it all depends on Wooper move
calculations in this position so when
you say time when you say time you
really mean timing like just just so the
precise thing that happens on move by
move let me ask you Peter you won Game
eight of your match against Kramnik to
take the lead in that match
psychologically what did that mean for
you because eventually he did win the
final game and a tied match ended up
costing you the chance to play any
tiebreak since there was no tie break in
effect a lot of players feel like a win
now would virtually be decisive a lot of
people commenting from the side feel
like a win now virtually would be
sigh civ in this match that's your
opinion as well given that you yourself
had a lead and didn't manage to hold it
yeah well I think that winning a game is
extremely important but it's just the
beginning of the match there are still a
lot of games and it's typically also the
dynamic of a match
once somebody wins then the other one
gets much more angry it's somehow much
focused because he knows that he needs
to strike back so also in the way he
approaches the opening preparation the
way he chooses the line the way the
seconds are working then you know that
there is no time for testing anymore
until the score is even you you feel
like okay there is nothing to lose
I mean why to take some extra risk if
you can try to get the information from
the open end by just testing him in
different lines once you lose it changes
dramatically then you feel like you
don't have any time to test you have to
go for it and this also gives your open
antigens and the whole match gets wide
open basically I think for the
spectators it's clear that whoever wins
sooner or later it will change the
dramatically dramaturgy of the home of
the match completely but the match is
only over when it's over I mean I knew
that I'm leaving before the last game
but I was not even thinking that I have
won the match because I knew that a
black game is still waiting for me and
also kind of you have to imagine the
players because we are watching the
games and we are kind of always fresh
for the game and we are looking forward
to the game but the players have
incredible attention to face during the
whole preparation phase of the match
than during the match
thus the seconds are working day and
night trying to find ideas they are
actually even if you don't see in the
games it doesn't mean that they are not
finding hundreds of ideas the only
problem is that when you are working
seriously then you also find the
antidote for your opponent and once you
find the antidote
you already kind of thing that they also
for day and night so they must
anticipate this idea and that's why it's
so difficult to to finally decide on
what you're going to play and once you
do something and it doesn't work out
it's very easy for the spectators to say
no of course he should have tried
something else but I mean in the pet
situation believe me it's it's extremely
difficult and you have to be also
practical
I think this choice of Fabiana was
definitely practical because it was
clear that modules could not have
anticipated this line maybe he has
looked at it a little bit but I mean you
don't have the luxury of spending with
every single setup days about that sorry
yes I just I'm just fascinated what he
said the idea of tension psychology even
fatigue your match was 14 games long if
I remember correctly how does how did
those soft factors not the hard chess
moves but the soft factors play a role
in the match yeah basically at I think
the last 5-6 days i was already hardly
able to eat anything I mean that was the
point the tension was already so much
and the program was also that I was
running out of openings openings with
black I mean those were prior computer
divas and it was much more difficult to
to switch to a new new opening to a new
opening so finally it was you know you
man you are you feeling that you are on
your limit physically mentally and you
still have to kind of come up with a new
opening to surprise kramnik because you
know that he has the best helpers in the
world and he has the best preparation in
the world then it's it's extremely tough
and I was hanging on I was also not
playing with white the lines that I was
normally feeling comfortable with yeah
because I doing the match I had to
switch to d4 and my usual opening
opening with white was a four so
was kind of also from the white side in
heavy pressure that's why I had even not
the slightest time to think about the
score I was just you know thinking about
the next game next game and final okay
chromic played a brilliant 14 game of
course I had a chance at one moment if I
would have used my chance maybe I would
have become the world champion at that
point but I missed that chance and then
he punished me recklessly and and that
was it he didn't give me a second chance
you talk about not able to eat how did
you manage that then you know the food
the tension what what did your handlers
trying to do to get you in the right
frame of mind what are these guys going
through with their handlers yeah well I
mean you have to ask them yeah everybody
handles attention differently I mean
back then it was also a different
situation because there was no tie
breaks so it's clear that if finally the
match would have been seven seven likely
ended probably the tension would have
been not that enormous because I would
still feel like you know then okay if I
lose that game I still have the tie
breaks but by knowing the fact that
simply if you lose that game or Kramnik
manages to to equalize the score then he
remains the champion this basically puts
a lot of pressure on you and maybe this
was also connected to it but I think the
rules were fair I mean I knew right from
the beginning that there is no tie break
so in this sense everything was was
normal and when you look at that that
chromic has defeated Kasparov and that's
how he became champion then you
understand that yeah in order to become
world champion you really have to beat
the champion Peter first of all hello
nice to see you again and thank you so
much for joining us double edged game
you mentioned that you're a fan of fab
B's preparation but in this exact
position if you had your choice of which
which color to play black or white what
would you prefer which which color would
you prefer and why not counting the
clock times not telling the clock times
well I mean generally I feel that
White's
vice position is preferable I mean
that's that's kind of my feeling but I
mean it can change in one move and as I
said everything depends on move by move
calculation
black will play Bishop f6 or maybe he
has played already because he has played
it yet let's anticipate Bishop f6 Peter
exactly yeah and and then already the
question is how to proceed with white I
mean I feel like you have two options
try to play before and c5 right away or
to move the bishop from FC to e4 but
that's when I'm saying time is a factor
of Bishop b4 might give a tempo and give
away the control over the g4 square
which black might be able to use with
Bishop g4 was on IG four so I think
already by playing Bishop d2 to c3
Fabiano has basically clarified his
intention that I'm gonna leave my pickup
on f3 and only once you play g4 I be a
considerable being it
I consider moving it because maybe after
g4 obeys Sam Bishop takes d5 is is a
possibility but and then the g4 pawn is
the kind of hanging another Duke on a1
is sometimes hanging also but it's
tactics now have two official g4 Bishop
takes a 1 I can take on c8
for example exactly and those actually
sacrifices can be extremely good for
white will be denied on b6 and with this
grip black suddenly has no compliments
ever not even to mention that after
Bishop e6 check there is some 97 fork if
if white really wants so I understand
the reason why
Magnus is thinking because here not
everything every movies is kind of
crucial you you just cannot allow
yourself make a move by hand and simply
later regret it because it might just
not work move bamboo Peter I'd like to
point out something else that I'm sure
you will have something to say about
because in this position also visual f6
cannot be met by another alternative to
move c5 blowing up the position and it
takes on c5 then d6 and suddenly White
has this big past pawn on d6 he's open
up the game and blacks King is looking
very exposed as well exactly I mean it's
also a typical idea in the King Simba
and often you see these dead white
sacrifice the pawn like c5 or if I have
to break the breaks black structure and
yeah once you push d6 and the knight on
e5 gets very vulnerable you get access
to the d5 square some Queen d5 check can
come with devastating effects so yeah
definitely
something to to think apart from the
black side this probably already means
that maybe Bishop f6 is not the best but
then what what exactly because c5 is
anyway hanging in the air yes the hinges
are trying to stop this move with Queen
c7 which seems a bit passive to me if
you gotta make moves like that you can't
be that happy
definitely exactly because then you lose
the tempo key and I you hit c4 home but
I'm also not sure if that's really a
threat yeah maybe maybe Black has to
play Queen c7 but it's certainly a move
that you don't really feel comfortable
doing that's because it it kind of shows
that maybe something went wrong but
maybe engine stays Queen c7 and
everything is under control it might
also be the case but during the game you
you are not deeper to to ask such
question to an engine so you are kind of
always uncertain and you don't feel
comfortable losing the tempo just to
stop some move like like c5 Peter before
the match probably you like many
thought that Magnus was a favorite did
you see him as a big favorite or not and
has the match surprised you in the sense
that it's been so evenly matched the
players no not at all I mean to be
honest I did not really consider Magnus
a favorite before the match because I
always consider that if somebody wins
the candidates and become the Challenger
then he might have very very close
chances I mean maybe not entirely the
same but if we are speaking in
percentage and you give one was a 55%
chance and Fabiano 45 it already shows
that it's extremely closed and we cannot
speak about real favorites basically the
question was that who will manage to put
his will on the opponent and who will be
more successful timing the right opening
the lines because it's clear that both
opponents are perfectly prepared and but
not you are not always able to show your
preparation yeah right and who will who
will be also in this sense a little bit
more lucky Magnus had to luck in the
first game because there everything went
his way then later
Fabiano had very nice preparations with
black and the games with black so this
is basically I think the first time we
see in during the match that somebody
really got something that he was looking
forward it white and black has to face
kind of problems at the board and and we
see how difficult that is
it takes time and energy Peter at this
point you made I mean there's so much
rich stuff about World Championship
matches that you're you're giving
insight into because the question then
becomes is it about who's the better
player necessarily or the breath the
better preparer because we could go back
in the history of these World
Championship matches
many people might argue while Carson was
clearly better than Anand when they
played that was pretty definitive
but unknown was supposed to be better
than gelfand and they played to a tie in
the first phase and and even I'm not
admitted man I could have lost that very
easily he only wanted one of the
tiebreak matches and then you saw uh nan
and Kramnik for example play and I nan
clearly outplayed him in their match but
if we go back to you and kramnik it was
a tied match people gave Gary the
favorite versus versus Kramnik and
cronic defeated him so there have been
all these upsets is it really about the
player or as you mentioned all those
soft factors like preparing
determination nerves of steel all those
things well I think you need a total
package because the point is that also
when a player feels that he is there
prepared it it might also influence his
play I mean he is much more calm and he
feels very happy he sleeps better you
know all these factors should simply not
be underestimated because and on the
other hand when you feel that you open
and is very prepared then you
automatically feel yourself uneasy
uncomfortable and you starts to see
ghosts you don't know what is the right
strategy and it's not even clear if the
opponent is playing so good or you are
playing war so you are not showing your
best and what is the reason for that I
mean normally is connected to the
opponent because whenever we say that
for example somebody is not in shape in
the World Championship match it's
probably because of his opponent that he
managed to find such a strategy for that
match which unbalanced you you are not
feeling easy you suddenly don't know
what to do with that and if a whole new
match could be played then things would
look completely different it's I I never
really like to say that with a better
player because you you never really can
judge this objectively I mean in in a
match and everybody has a chance
everybody is we're prepared everybody's
very well motivated you know that this
is the chance of your lifetime you are
spending all your
energy so all these factors should
should be taken into consideration and I
think that's why it's never clear for
example Kasparov against Kramnik looked
like he was not in shape but if Kramnik
would have not killed his groom fat in
the first wide game in the match and
later he would have not been such a good
and very prepared guy in the Berlin by
basically forcing gali to go crazy I
mean we didn't see Korea that match the
way we used to see him and then we can
say that he was simply not in here but
if maybe Graeme could have chosen any
other opening then we would have seen
one of the best Kasparov enduring the
exact same match so it's it's always
very tricky as you were as you were
talking amang goes into a deep think but
he finally made a move Bishop to f5
instead of the Bishop f6 that we were
actually predicting and the engines hate
the move they think this move is really
bad because of c-5 giving a much bigger
edge even than before with this
breakthrough c5 what's going on to it
you haven't had to use the tempo before
before at all three you get one for free
what could Magnus be thinking here well
imagine after c5 Bishop f6 White has
gotten in and c5 but has he necessarily
resolved this the central play to his
advantage Bishop f6 after c5 Peter how
do you see the move Bishop f5
I mean before the engine told you it was
a bad move it doesn't look so bad to the
naked eye does it exactly I mean the
whole point is that after the Bishop f5
is a developing move black was still
having this problem that the bishop on C
it is kind of stuck you feel like if you
keep that Bishop there forever then you
are not going to create enough counter
play and maybe I mean you have to take a
decision
as we already spoke before to play just
some Queen c7 it feels too slow playing
Bishop f6 than also into c5
so you you develop the bishop and you
hope for the best
exactly but isn't a problem still that
this pawn got down the board you go to
c6 and it's always threatening c7 like
even in this line to move c6 can get
played and something like rook c1
threats of just it looks like White has
arrived and blacks play just seems
somewhat nebulous if you will of course
you still got to worry about your king
but I'm not as worried yet by black
scoring the touchdown with rook going to
see one and this threat of c7 always
hanging in the air well to be honest I'm
worried of c5 but I'm not that worried
about c6 because I I do feel that once
you push the six yeah I understand you
get a great asset on on the sixth but
study early I also get a very nice
control of the e5 square for my knight
and white is not gonna unbalance it so
easily and exactly after some look f7 I
have control of the seventh rank and I
might try to learn some contests like on
the King side it's probably not that
easy and I know that against computers
usually those feelings somehow never
work out for some exact move per move
specific reasons but humanly speaking I
think you do worry about c5 but if you
feel that after c5 Bishop f6 White's
best is to go c6 then you kind of take
it like okay I know it okay that's
what's happening if the position is
already dangerous but this case I will
also have my chance to to create contra
play on the Kings I mean a nice Theory
has tweeted Peter as as this position
has come on the board that most likely
team Carlson's file says something like
you play a foreign move 18 instead of g5
and then after work a4 you play g5
positing that actually Magnus captain
used and that g5 is a red one first of
all what is the phrase red one mean do
you know what that means that just means
like a stoplight like a bad variation
and also do you agree with the
audience's assessment that Magnus
probably was mixing up preparation here
well maybe he was mixing but I'm not
sure that it was really prepared I mean
yeah because he spent so much time even
to get to that position yes but in in
general yet the point is that when he
played g5 that's the moment when black
steel has the opportunity to play
possession of it Bishop g5 I think right
right so I ditch was saying like yes we
played g5 but only in a position where
there's a little bit more commitment for
ye yeah I see his point I mean basically
another question is what he was probably
pointing out that you first go f4 and
once white loses some tempo then you're
going to play g5 because once you
already pushed therefore that is just a
question of time when you're going to
push g5 but yeah somehow he might have
he might have mixed it up because it's
little bit surprising how he got into so
much trouble usually I know that these
positions are tricky but they are not
supposed to be that good for white how
well great
it's just complicated but that it
suddenly
engines are giving all over the place
huge advantage for my tip shows that
black problem is missed a move order
well one final few final questions Peter
because I know you have to get going to
play tennis table nice do you have time
so it's no hurry things
Oh wonderful great well we'd love to
keep you on for the next 15 minutes then
before we go on break question about a
the you're from Hungary and the official
commentator over in London is Judit
Polgar as well as hungry exactly right
both on an owl is in Spain but she was
originally from Hungary right so um have
you been on you've been on lots of
Olympic teams with Judah right
you kind of describe what it's like to
work with her well I mean I never really
worked with her but we play together yes
a lot together I think we started
playing in the national team in 94
that's when I debuted in in Moscow and
by the way we have played the game with
Yasser their theoretical clash in the
grim field and I think the stevia
variation yeah it was it was a
fascinating game that was our first game
together yes sir yeah and since then we
have played a lot of lot of Olympics
together with Judy we have won two
silver medals in 2000 played Olympics
and 2014 in Toms show so we have really
many many great memories together a lot
of times the US team is also quite
similar that the players kind of come as
individuals they don't they work
together as a team a little bit but
maybe less than certain other squads
like Armenia for instance it sounds like
it's kind of a similar thing in Hungary
where it's a lot of great individuals
that come together for one event yeah
it's it's kind of the usual scene in
chess because simply as a top player you
automatically have your own team I mean
your own coaches and things like this
with whom you are working on your
openings and you it is always a problem
to share your thoughts openly with
someone who you considered also a
survival yeah because you can play in
individual tournaments then suddenly
also facing each other starts to be kind
of unpleasant because if you're open and
knows exactly what you are thinking
about certain lines then you really have
a problem and also your opponent has a
problem that's why players even if they
have good relation with each other they
prefer not to get in interaction it
basically doesn't really mean that the
players are not good friends but simply
just it doesn't work if you're going to
play the next tournament against each
other and you have nothing to play so
everybody refers for himself but for the
success of a team it's always very
important that the team has a good
I mean if if there is tension between
the players somehow I don't believe that
you can really succeed in a team event
Peter are we really have to take a look
I really want to get your opinion now in
this position because the engines really
are going crazy and saying that this
position is virtually dead loss for
Magnus and some of the thematics include
actually taking this night off of e5
eventually and then putting the move
Bishop to g4 to eliminate this piece so
a move like c5 is a really strong
looking move as far as the Angels
concerned because of this main problem
and it looks like what one main line
runs Knight f3 queen of 3d c5 and then
just simply working well just go down
upon and say this position is also just
busted move like Bishop f6 can be met by
h4 even and the angels are claiming that
this black has no real counter play and
it is white with the bind in this
position would you what's your feeling
your gut feeling is this these kind of
lines are starting to develop because
that plan of playing Bishop takes e5
maybe slightly counterintuitive but when
it's followed up by Bishop g4 very
concrete now it's looking really
concrete and that sequence started to
rest on the board and we're talking
about back here in this position with c5
a move like Bishop f6 can get played but
but then the move c6 again this idea
coming in the game and then something
like takes and then maybe Bishop g4
something like this is what the engine's
going for not exactly in this position
in fact first I believe they want to
guard this pawn on c6
and then start the captures in this line
so maybe Queen c7 first let's start with
this move and then go for the threat of
Bishop takes e5 with Bishop g4 and
suddenly white is shutting down all of
blacks play and it's and it's white and
starting to overtake overrun the black
position yeah I mean I I simply think
that it's obvious for every good player
that white is better here some it's
clear that something went wrong black is
missing the tempo at least from his
counter play the only question is always
to choose between the option
because while for the engine it's the
quite obvious that AHA this one is plus
1 plus 2 or whatsoever for a human eye
you kind of think differently and you
also first of all want to break the open
end structure it has some high to low
base feels that by breaking the
structure it it helps as you save this
Bishop takes t5 detects if I pick up g4
is also kind of positional because white
wants to eliminate the light square
Bishop sand than some queen g4 Queen e6
check might appear and blacks center
bones might collapse so I would think
that the line that you mentioned the
Bishop e5 defy Bishop g4 is not not
entirely computer ish it's definitely
something that Fabiano is not really
considering on the other hand c4 c5 is
so tempting but the question is once you
understand that you have to play you
play c5 and the open and close Bishop f6
and you don't have anything better than
c6 then you kind of you get hesitant and
you start to think that a hoang go but
then maybe I still prefer more to take
on e5 and go Bishop g4 because maybe
it's more clear-cut
I mean usually humanly speaking you
always would like to get some more
clarity in the position and but on the
other hand sometimes you have to give
your opponent the chance for counter
play and simply calculate deep enough to
be sure that you you are getting a lot
of top on it what seems to me like it's
likely that for the first time in the
game Fabiano is no longer in his
preparation i I mean I'm not sure about
that even maybe he he anticipated Bishop
f5 and and I was thinking I'm trying to
review since of course it wasn't his
main line what's your take on that you
agree that looking at the clock times
and also the logic of the previous moves
that Bobby might be thinking for the
first time right now yes that's that's
the case but I'm already pretty sure
that Fabiana is out of any kind of
preparation by now I mean first of all
this
I was not people before the match it was
prettier than I doing the match once you
get the information that the session you
cover is played and basically once you
have these thoughts that you even cannot
really find any antidote to it then you
find first light to find a way to get a
playable position and if you get a
playable position that's already
something and when you are preparing
then you are assuming that you'll open
and definitely is very well prepared so
you are mainly analyzing the best
options for blacks so that's the point
that when suddenly black mixes up things
with g5f for them probably at home the
second is instead of g5 he is working
maybe 10 hours on f4 and g5 he just says
ok g5 is just a bad move because it
loses a tempo and okay you're gonna go
c4 and okay you are good enough you know
how to how to treat this position and
and I think definitely already after
this bishops tease they might have been
the last move kind of in a preparation
but it's probably also not as a
preparation just maybe as a thought that
okay you know you know I mean your plan
is to go c4 and Bishop CC I put pressure
on the night and let's keep going
exactly if I remember correctly Peter
you were not just a World Championship
challenger you were also a second
weren't you a second
it was it Ananta polliver anon Kramnik
you were second yeah I have been second
thing in two matches actually and both
matches went like a disaster for my
player so it's quite natural to blame me
for that but exactly also for that
reason I know that how special these
matches are I mean I was daring in the
match anand versus Kramnik as a second
of chromic and I mean yeah those melih
lines went completely out of control
however later on I had the feeling that
if the match would have been longer then
already the the situation changed in
favor of cramming and
he then won one game and he got down to
only - to score and if that would have
been still four or six games then I
believe that Vlade very much would have
been still in game because suddenly the
preparation was switching to two hour
angle and at the first part of the match
vicious openings were working very well
we had more like regular preparation she
had a very specific preparation and at
the beginning he offered us but in long
terms time was on our side but they were
simply not enough games and we she want
the match deservedly and then we had the
match between anandam Carson the first
match in Chennai when I worked with BC
and there also it was very interesting
because there we managed to out prepare
Magnus said in the first games and we
she thought all his opening to black and
even had to to play but he fell - to
utilize daring his great chances in Game
three and then when suddenly Magnus on
Game four managed to play the Berlin and
realized that which is kind of not
entirely ready for that that
psychologically changed the whole match
and I felt like Magnus Condon and we
have seen then one was in top shape in
the remaining of the games but if he
would have not that in game for this
this that aha finally I'm secure V black
then the match could have actually taken
a completely different turn very good
Peter before we let you go two quick
questions first who's your competition
and ping pong like can anybody play with
you in the chess world and second I
think you also like myself have a great
deal of admiration for Dingley rin and
his unbeaten streak of 100 games that
was quite an extraordinary achievement
your thoughts yeah well actually coming
back
- tingly Ron I think I'm 2009 I played
in Nanjing and it was a super tournament
at that point England was still very
very young and I gave a press conference
there and I was telling the Chinese
audience already that I think England
will be a superstar and they were kind
of surprised that why I'm mentioning
that because okay they already had
Superstars and he still young but I said
no he will be one of the best players I
think and finally it proved right I mean
I saw from his games and I saw his
determination that he is really willing
to invest everything for for chess and
basically chest is such a sport that the
more you invest the more benefits you
are getting back and and somehow okay
those streaks of hundred games you can
never really expect those things they
just happen but it was definitely
incredible he also played the candidates
tournament and he was often in the
candidates and not by playing for draws
because I actually felt really sorry for
Ford England and after like eight or
nine games of draws people just talking
about
so you can only draw things like this
but when you look at the games you saw
that every game had a real content and
this is actually what really comes in in
my eye not the final result simply that
you're not really willing to play a VHS
and then finally it's a draw or you are
just playing for a true and and I mean
the England's result was that's why so
impressive because I think with white
he's always very a player and also with
black he never shied away from
complications so if you really managed
to get hundred games without a loss it's
some incredible achievement and
ping-pong usually whenever I'm in China
it's also connected to China then we
play a lot of ping-pong the same
tournament in Nanjing which was actually
Magnus's breakthrough because he was
already one of the very best
in the word but after winning Nanjing in
2009 with an impressive score that's
when he became first time number one in
the list I think and during during those
those games I mean in the breaks were
playing every evening table tennis with
Magnus with Raja both I mean with the
Chinese players it was really a very
nice gathering but only after the
tournament we got to know that what we
are playing table tennis with each other
Kasparov was helping and second in
Magnus Carlsen and back then this
cooperation was completely secret and
after the tournament I kind of felt like
well if I would have known that
information during the tournament I
would have maybe reacted little bit
differently also to those Table Tennis
sessions very good Peter thank you so
much for joining us and sharing your
thoughts especially your experiences
about the world championship matches and
what it was like to be both a player and
a second and and the special kind of
specialists so really the timing today
was perfect that you joined us yeah the
invitation it was also a pleasure and
keep up the show it's always fascinating
to to follow you and it's so wonderful
to get him on the air but you know we
we'd never had him is in st. Louis were
recording the show you gotta come to st.
Louis right here right now
join us we're we're very hospitable we
like to have guests you gotta get on
that couch with more ease right but we
will we love to hear from you and yeah
we just have to watch this game unfold
as we got Peter on and what might be the
most exciting game on the mat thank you
Peter thank you yeah thank you
before we go on break just take us
through what you think or what as the
engine things
the most concrete and best moves oh we
went over the line it's already c5 is
looking massive you have to play c5 well
if you want to kill him you do yeah it's
a thematic move in the position okay the
thing about it that's a strange thing
and I'm totally fascinated by is c5 is a
pawn sacrifice
I mean you are giving away your pawn
your knife your bishops and the end of
the two bishops and you're not giving it
away this pawn and then saying okay now
I make you now here's the attacking line
the quiet rook a e1 which by itself
doesn't even contain a threat like
what's what's the next did you play rook
anyone in the sack no no you're just
playing yet another move this bull c5 is
it's giving a massive advantage for all
the dynamic reasons the strong night the
past pawn the beautiful diagonal line
and the chance to crack open that side
of the board with h4 that stuff is deep
I'm sorry that's way way deep to
understand and assess your a pawn down
just shows you how computers have become
that much more advanced because back in
the day they'd seen the pawn up and
they'd be scrambling to say I'm better
I got a pawn what are you talking about
slowly but surely counterplay started
battering more pieces and and weak
squares and pass pawns
got sort more and more value and then
the computer starts saying well we don't
care so much about material anymore but
this isn't this is extreme this is I
just have a great position I got all the
play what are you going to do as my
pieces are just fantastic and you don't
have much to do in as a matter of fact
after a move like this
I'm ready to just go hog wild and slowly
but surely I'm gonna get you this
reminds me of what alpha zero did in its
match against stockfish we remember how
it was sacrificing pawns for
compensation right here's a pawn here
and all of us I mean top grandmas were
going wait where's the comp right and
then it would make some funky moves I
remember it made one move Queen h1 as
white here like he's down
what Bobby's going in for his first
think of the game image yeah that's not
the kind of position this is is that
will you assess it that it's just better
for you straight upon down with with
generalized compensation looks good but
not concrete it's it's a hard move to
play because you are definitely psyching
upon and you're not gonna see it back
for a while well in the concept though
could have been prepared pregame with a
more natural-looking Bishop f6 move that
you might Peter said somewhere around
Bishop c3 but it's very feasible that it
could have gone bishop c3 Bishop at 65
NBN yeah so therefore Bobby's already
aware these pawn sacrifice idea cuz
that's a pawn sacrifice to absolutely
Knight a3 Queen of three takes on c5 so
I think that Fabia Zack is thinking
about I want to say Kavala is that the
right name anyway I remember seeing the
idea for the first time and then in a
real open set of that turn into
transpose into a Kings Indian yeah
against Boris crimen I remember I played
I'm going back way back though where I
got to play this move c5 and it was a
similar idea you just looked at he said
well it looks like upon it my opponent
took the pawn and it was just pure
long-term compensation I eventually
caught him on the like squares then
sacrificed my Queens to get a beautiful
mating formation but c5 is a typical
idea you just every time you look at it
have to assess is it good now is it good
now you know do I need to play before
first or will that be a tempo loss
because c5 is a risk you go down upon
you see the idea that's great but you're
you're playing the game thanks a lot for
you guys analyzing in the computer
helping you but you're playing the game
and you want me to give that guy you
know who I'm playing yeah upon my and I
don't see it's my pawn and I don't see
clearly how I'm winning the game that's
the challenge when you look at this
position optically it definitely looks
good for white blacks
has like cavernous holes in the position
this night is very strong in the past
play it looks really good for white it's
somebody has to tell you oh by the way
you're down upon wait wait what goes on
to the wing of the game that way then it
would certainly fit on on Don's criteria
of a fitting victory in the world oh yes
oh yes but we're gonna take a break
Fabiano thanks for the first time in the
game but so far he has won the opening
battle and as we go to break we're gonna
share with you a fireside chat we're up
to the Kasparov Karpov rivalries in the
1990s I hope you enjoy the clip now for
me as the Karpov Kasparov world
championships right really the time that
I came in to chest my maturity watching
those matches and talk about classic it
starts right away good guy bad guy I'm
Rudy focus para immediately right good
good right or wrong right because he's
the young gun going what it looks like
against the old guard right and also
somehow against the Soviet establishment
right maybe it's not the right storyline
maybe it's a little bit of propaganda
but that's what it feels like and he has
come on like a storm and you know
because you played him I mean he was 22
years old competing against this Karpov
guy who has been dominant for nine years
exactly so we have five World
Championship matches between these two
extraordinary chess players who are
extraordinarily different chess players
as well so there is Anatoly Karpov which
to me as a player he's like the pinnacle
of the positional scientific technical
school from Steinitz
to BA Vinick to literally to Anatoly
Karpov he is standing you know on top of
the shoulders of giants and
his technique his practical play he
played very quickly he was just a phenom
I mean where was his weaknesses how do
you beat this guy this guy's just
incredible and then there's this guy
Rico Kasparov character you know a book
a page right out of the NM michael tall
how the kind school Alex Claire and
chaos chaos chaos chaos and they they
start their first match 1984 under the
rules that you gotta win six you gotta
win six games draws don't count five
five you play to the sixth victory so
you got to win six and it's like after
nine Karpov is just dominating this guy
he's up like four zip and after 28 games
it's five zip zip
I consider Garry Kasparov a goat V goat
the greatest of all times but he's
losing that first match five zip well he
had beaten other players but he had
never faced somebody like Karpov and
Karpov was making it look easy easy but
then apparently Kasparov made a phone
call to Moscow called up his old trainer
Mikhail Botvinnik
who told me how to stabilize things and
make some drawers right and then we just
kept seeing draw after drawing 17
straight draw a rearguard action games
that were just finishing quickly and
right now the chess world was wondering
right what's going on
right matches past a month two months
three months and we're going what's
going on is anybody ever gonna win this
they're saying Karpov is looking like he
said the door of death itself right wait
he's losing from the stress unable to
break through this youngster and win one
more game right so it was game 32 that's
he's supposed to win I mean he's gonna
win game 32 he has a winning position
does Anatoly Karpov if he wins that game
match is over
zip I don't think we ever hear from
garry kasparov again statement really
yeah
he's lost yeah I mean it's a it's easy
demonstratable will but somehow Gary
saves that then finally gets on the
board with a victory and then comes
games 47 and 48 you just jumped because
I just got a lot more draws in between
that was the rearguard action of the 15
16 17 straight draws that you were just
mentioning and then he put through
back-to-back victories does garry
kasparov and now the match is 5 to 3 but
it's gone six months actually it was
kind of funny
because do you remember the days of
Ronald Reagan when there were so many
people who were dying in the Soviet
political that he was complaining you
know every time I establish a
relationship with one of the premiers he
dies and they were playing in the Hall
of columns Hall of columns these big big
big columns these big marble columns
where they would bury these leaders
anyway the point was was the match was
being held in this very very prestigious
venue and it went for like 16 months 6
months 6 months I know the long man six
months sorry I went sixteen six months
my friend our friend Jonathan Tisdale
was there he only learned Russian he was
like the Reuters AP guy you know
stationed in Moscow you know you thought
he was there for a chess match he stayed
there for six months and trying to
organize such a match you know give it a
feed a at least it's do you're trying to
run such a match and the match never
ends you can't possibly happen
all those drawers when you think about
something like sugaring Stein it's for
example jacory versus nine Stein it's
they had a match that was 17 games long
and the first 16 games were decisive
exactly one draw was the last game right
just guys to have now have a match where
there's so many draws really did seem
unimaginable exactly exactly and so
there was a big problem there no nobody
is saying there wasn't a big problem but
the
that's was score was five to three when
the president of the fidei Florencio
compa Montes made a very controversial
decision he annulled the match he just
said that's it matches over we're gonna
play a new match starting at 0-0
but we're gonna go back to the old rules
of 24 games so Karpov of course
protested he said look I'm leading five
to three all I got to do is win one game
Gary says that's fair you know let's go
and then comes the second match and Gary
wins becoming the youngest world
champion in the history of our history
and then that starts a series like we
have never seen and probably again the
same two guys fight for the world
championship five matches in a row
it's whether car club has to win the
last game or Gary has to magically win
the last game right in order to tie the
match to keep his tie only thing you can
imagine I mean they were separated by
something like one game after after all
the matches all the games that they play
their score was that close Gary might be
the greatest player of all time but
there was this one guy who he was not
able to dominate exactly and
statistically it was just a push and yet
having said that stylistically you
couldn't have two more dynamic opposed
players Anatoly was this incredible
technician Gary this incredible
tactician so you're a basically an
immovable force versus an unstoppable
object and the two of them showed us
matches that that will sit forever in
the history of chess with some games
that's it forever as well the two of
them really played classic matches
vintage matches that will go down as
some of the greatest in the history of
chess
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to today in tests
World Championship position the men are
deadlocked the top two players in the
world but today
Fabiano playing some lovely preparation
has gotten into a fantastic position
against Magnus Carlsen he did play the
pawn profit sacrifice c5 and after a
very quick Knight takes out three Queen
takes f3 pawn takes c5 by Magnus he did
not play the move that you were
mentioning Maurice rook e1 and instead
played another move I was thinking Bob
you might actually think for a little
bit between work do you want and rook
Ilan because they both seem attractive
yes rook t1 resonating d6 taking
advantage of the pin on I mean taking
advantage of the corridor if the rook
and the Queen I mean it just seems like
we're kd1 the opponent's gonna have to
Magnus is gonna have to blockade with
Bishop d6 it's like I can't imagine you
can just let that pawn land on these
anyway right so here your right to very
compelling moves rook d1 as chosen by
Fabiana rook e1 was the engine's first
choice and this is a difficult move to
play because it doesn't as you say have
a very concrete threat whereas the
choice of Fabiano when to play rook do
you want it does contain a very concrete
threat of playing for d 56 and why would
you think that you want to move the
Bishop to d6 is that because now that
c3h8 diagonal is you before vulnerable
because you can't take the bishop on
that 6th to counter it so it's so funny
could easily think that this work a dear
one is a really useful finesse rectum
back in the Bishop to d6 oh absolutely
very attractive to make this concrete
threat move but the idea is you know
rooks belong and open files too and here
it was about this move H to H for which
maurice had pointed out breaking up the
team on the King side and really just
generating nasty threats and asking
black what's he going to do he has to
very very passive major pieces the rook
on f8 the rook on
even the Queen on d8 is not contributing
where as whites
all of whites pieces feel a lot more
active in any case after Knight takes
after Queen takes f3 takes we did see
this move rook d1 and let's go for some
sample some sample line so after Bishop
d6 stopped with Bishop e6 now what about
just coming in with Queen to h5 Queen h5
and checkmate no longer on that diagonal
you can't play for Bishop f6 kind of
shoring up everything right right okay
so so just if I force your hand okay so
I play Queen eight six now h6 yes of
course threatening checkmate in one you
can see why you'd want of course you'd
want your book on e one cuz you could
play rook e6 with the devastating threat
of Brookhaven do you think precisely
that was one of the reasons why the
engine preferred the rook on the open
file let's go nonetheless well I I do
have the idea of Bishop f8 a forced
evacuation you're backing up on the move
Bishop FH and your queen is gonna have
to force all the way back to h3 so that
was it's not that the move Queen h5 is
premature not at all
it's why the move h4 as a pray prelude
to Queen did I blunder something I think
I'm cool under it something I've noticed
that the mercury on the left just wants
oh I'm sorry g5 g for Queen takes h4 oh
okay sorry and you're just you're
actually the one who's getting made it
I'm the one who's getting made into that
particular case but Maurice rook on a
one to d1 a very attractive move the
engines preferred rook
one this despoil yeah you like you said
and I completely concur you don't want
to see d5 d6 land on the board that
that's a runaway criminal that pawn on
d6 so Bishop d6 blockading seemed
obliged passed pawn should be rocked up
like a credible yeah yeah that passed
pawns they should be put behind the lock
and key he had a wonderful turn of
phrase always said that he was a
terrible author but wonderful turn of
phrase no question Maurice rook on a1 to
d1 very attractive move does not
anything no it was not as good as the
other one but the advantage is so big
that white is completely controlling
this position and this threat of d6 of
course was monstrous Bishop d6
blockading natural but now this move
Queen to h5 immediately immediately
immediately almost putting block in some
kind of zips long Howard do you know how
do you move your pieces around now what
do you do move like Bishop to g6 will
creepy-crawly a little bit closer to you
we got a little mate thread here right
but notice what's happening to blacks
pieces they're turning there they're
beginning to get highly specific and
when they start getting too specific
they become stultified like they have to
play exactly this role and nothing else
if you get into that situation you have
a problem what I mean by that is this
Queen has to defend this pawn so even
after work have seven years you can't
play Queen f8s they have a natural kind
of move to chase the Queen out because
the pawn is hanging the bishop has got a
blockade the rook stuck the rooks busy
doing work some of your pieces are
getting into this [ __ ] this defensive
functions and now White's gonna stop and
go hmm okay my pieces are flexible how
do i crack you in this position here the
engine gives rook F II 1 as the next
move and you just feel flow rook is
gonna land now on e6 new threat to your
positions how do you handle that threat
rookie six wits with sacrifices
abounding on g6 what do you do
white has complete control of this
position every white piece is fabuloso I
want to say fabuloso
quickly but anyway beautiful night
beautiful bishop rooks on open files
Queen posted up look at blacks game
black is like this I got a pawn but the
guys gonna come punch me in the face and
it's coming complete control disposition
for White Queen h5 a monster move but it
doesn't really matter it's about the
position and the pieces and white is
definitely dominant here and the engines
love White's position okay well there
you have it
Junior your queen h5 and queen h6
is getting two thumbs up i buy the chess
engines yeah i was taking a look at
twitter so the idea against your your
moves were as it was that was white at
the end okay so we saw the move Bishop
d6 Queen h5 I went Bishop g6 you went
Queen h6 I went look F 7 if I miss
something here and then it was rook e1
and after Bishop f8 what the the engines
conclusion was that this bishop is lousy
this Bishop is not doing that much all
of whites pieces are really good this
record in particular also not doing
great
d5 d6 rookie 6 Bishop e5 lots of very
nice moves and whites pieces were just
simply being so much more flexible than
blacks blacks was being corralled into
playing a very specific role what did
you call not ossified but as a threat is
right and black is basically on the bat
back foot with no active pieces so it
was just a nice little judgment call
there I even see rookie 6 Bishop f5 in
some position there's being an exchange
sacrifice sorry say that again moving so
even if you stop me from
let's say you play Bishop Bishop back to
d6 to stop me there feels like a rookie
six Bishop f5 exchange sacrifice
possibly even Queen can go back to h6 it
looks at the Queen something like this
as well Bobby don't touch that rook
matter of fact this brings me to another
point we like it with this convergence
because God Echo's yeah we got that goes
we got echoes this game between anon and
Kasparov when I was looking at this
position I thought wait a minute I've
seen something similar before a
challenger with the white pieces after a
lot of draws going on the attack against
the champion this was game 9 of the 1995
World Championship match where I played
this move before getting the action
going against his Queen you cannot touch
the pawn because the route goes to the
Father after Queen a5 Bishop b6 wins the
exchange he dropped back b5 breaking
through on the Queen side this was the
novelty and after a trade Knight takes
and after Bishop takes
excuse me Bishop takes in this position
Queen takes jumping back to the position
rook e8 c 4e 5 and now we talked about
white getting dominance on the Queen
side of the board and that b6 square
Queen c8 a trade a5 and after Bishop f8
this nice little to move h3 Queen e6 and
rook to d5 I love that rookie 6 exchange
sacrifice now in this position he was
not supposed to take the rook
don't touch that rook but Kasparov
couldn't help himself
any sauce he could play the move like h5
and wait but after 85 85 Queen g6 e5 e
for Bishop e2 looking at the
breakthrough c5 happening and all the
pressure rookie 5 then he played Queen
to d7 to deal with a little bit of
demonstration on this side and then d6
with dominance this is the kind of thing
we're talking about where white breaks
through the Queen side why he doesn't
have enough play or any play f7 f5 never
got played and white breaks through
picked off the b-pawn the game ended
actually kind of nicely rook g3 queen b7
and then Queen b6 king h2 a nice move
stopping the rook h3 threat and daring
you to play the move Queen e5 in this
position because Queen e5 I just ignore
you take your rook and say what
discovery do you have that means
anything at all because barb didn't want
to see this position any resign but the
point being that player on the Queen
side by the Challenger to affect with
those ones the breakthrough happens you
don't have to kind of play you die so
here we see the exchange sacrifice in
this game back at Harbor Alert Queen H I
was not playing h3 and we're going we
played a move Queen e8 which seems like
a great move yes I hate I hate to say it
being on Team Fabi this mirror looks
like a very slow and fabi's it threatens
if you get up to the current position
after age three Queen EA we have it on
the green it threatens Queen to e3 check
and if you play like rook e1 now I stick
my queen on g6 but she looks like a
great square for both attack and defense
I'm defending the dark squares but I'm
also looking at getting my counter play
with g4 so you know earlier a Peter said
it's all about timing and Magnus looks
like he's down a temple or two mm-hmm
and by bringing the Queen into the
action it kind of looks like
Magnus is rebounded timewise just a
little bit h3 the problem it's really
slow big time well the Queen on d8 was
really bothering nobody
and the Queen on g6 is far superior Lee
placed as you said already you're you're
protecting some crucial squares is black
and you're introducing your own source
of counter play with g5 g 4 no question
about it
h2 h3 that very very hesitant move was
the culprit and may be costing white a
significant part of his amana huge huge
mistake queen h5 throwing away the
better part of his advantage this move
was just too quiet
he needed to play actively and by
playing h3 giving his opponent a
straight tempo to fix this position now
the Queen goes to e8 and the ages are
now saying white has
a small edge at best and for a working
one though it was giving a huge it
doesn't matter what you play here
doesn't matter it doesn't matter your
already talked away your big advantage
good night see for now you're asking
isn't any good just your question is
telling you the answer what you did now
he's very active but you can see there's
my look kinda tempting that you're
trying to to you know pileup on the v6
plot point but the problem I guess is
night see for Queen g6 is a good reply
right you're willing to give up the
bishop and how that has that position
look though he has with the bishops of
opposite color I mean wouldn't it still
look a little better for y8 night see
Ford queen g6 Knight takes Queen takes
well it was funny in the echo game that
maurice was showing us that that piece
that was discussed on b6 remained on b6
and I'm not that big a fan of what has
just hate trans this hasn't happened yet
no you wouldn't know you were saying 94
you wanted me to look at night c4 I
thought that and I don't have time to
maybe I thought Age 3 was the wrong oh
oh but it was played yeah it does what
is Fabi thinking have in mind did he
miss the idea of Queen e8 or do you
think perhaps what about this what about
h3 rook e1 queen g6 994 aren't i
threatening something like rookie six
maybe like some of these exchange
sacrifices that we just though we
already talked about maybe you are I
don't know I'm just saying that from the
very start
maybe rook d1 I'm not a big fan of I
mean again if you were locally what
should black be trying to do with a
species well obviously you should be
trying to activate them this rook on b8
is terrible right so to get this work of
me b8 into the game you're gonna have to
move your queen
where does your queen belong well I
would say g6 so one of the one of the
starting moves rook on a1 to e1 really
stops you from getting your Queen to g6
you're not going so part of the
brilliance of this move is actually the
prophylactic qualities and just to shut
down any any activity by black now in
the game after
d1 Bishop d6 we seem we've seen players
build up advantages okay but we've also
seen hesitant moves correct once they
get those advantages it's sort of like
they want to nurse them without taking
any risk or anything like that
and after h3 we need very very sharp no
I'm saying that white should try to get
the advantage back you want to play
Knight see before I want to look at
lines like what about like working one
we're going to act at you on the idea of
trying to get a rookie six phases either
now obviously with 94 it would be a
strong but with what if I just start
with rookie six that just doesn't lead
to anything you just take twice right
and there's nothing there at the end of
the day well remember you've got one
pawn down
so you've sacrificed a second pawn and
you've sacrificed an exchange yeah I
know but I mean that Bishop my pieces
all look awesome so maybe I have some
waiting where your pieces were awesome
before you second what is okay I mean
Queen g6 you can't play no of course not
but yeah but I mean this was what what
is just trying to take on I look at
people like Queen e7 I was thinking I
could like maybe take and take on g5 but
you always have clean g6 at the end
right that's a problem what happens if
okay maybe Queen h5 is not that good do
I have another move here well the
computer says you have compensation gen
but it doesn't say you have any
advantage anymore it says like you've
really spoiled things for why what I
start with made people with the idea of
trying to get working one working school
the problem now is you I've given you
the time let me just activate my rook I
I'm dreaming of that rook on b8 playing
actually a function you know for such a
long period of time whatever move number
has been the rook on B ADA's has been a
spectator I shall work e6 and I'm
captured at the end - did I miss taking
on b7 last night the work is on PA of
course right now that I've beckoned you
to d8 can i play this line with b7
hanging oh you have you're not taking on
e6 well I'm not sure that like I'm happy
that's why I practiced in exchange and
your trade off Brooks I'll probably play
working on and I don't want to trade off
rooks no you guys before you start come
play claiming compensation just like
four months ago you had a huge advantage
why would you have compensation you know
I know one of these lines I'm sure he
thought something yeah what he thought
was not that good unfortunately uh the
other thing to point out here is the
thing about rook d1 sorry which one you
mentioned back before work before you
played rugby one
the thing about rugby one is it's pretty
clear he's gonna play Bishop d6
certainly there's nitrogen if I mean
even if I don't play rook D what he's
gonna play Bishop d6 like it does yeah I
like black to move what is black gonna
do he's gonna play Bishop he's gonna
play Bishop d6 agreed right so that
really unless he felt black could also
play Bishop f6 which smells smells but
maybe maybe that's what he suppose that
this move could be on the board because
rook t1 doesn't have a point if black is
gonna play Bishop d6 it's like you made
him play a move that he wants to play
anyway desperate right he's really
trying to figure out how to reorganize
his pieces so he's thinking Bishop d6
Queen e8 between g6
those are his next several moves those
are the most natural moles trying to
play so rook d1 may not throw it throws
away some advantage because rook e1
insists on the same position where with
your rook on the open file and you get
going exactly well unless unless he also
felt like he wanted the other rook to go
to e1
maybe he wanted his cake and the
chocolate and ice cream and the gelato
and everything as
right so he wanted to have both rooks on
the files and the point on h3 so a guy
gets no counterplay and the guys waiting
around watching him I beautify his
position right and nothing is gonna
happen so maybe that's what really would
went on in his mind the issue of the
wrong rook because if your book is stuck
on f1 then it looks like you don't have
a future right so it's possible that he
was trying to double rooks instead that
his place works on d1 e1 and now it
turns out the timing was not quite right
and now he's realizing he's a big
advantage is has been fretted away when
you played c5 you wanted more than what
he's getting now yeah and he really
wanted to get his rook to e6 he was
afraid of g4 GN we have a caller in the
phone sorry no I don't really I mean
even if we're not you know we think that
h3 is not the best move it's a move this
position is so completely thrilling as I
mean no question this game could end up
being a sacrificial victory for Fabi I
saw a tweet that's reporting that on
chess comm grandmaster he's our Cara
Nakamura thinks that once you slip once
against Magnus with with them after
playing c5 that it's likely that it will
start to slip away more and he's liking
the position for Maggie now well but you
know but you car was also set from the
very beginning that he thinks Magnus is
a heavy favorite so his opinion seems to
like fit with his overall opinion is
what I'm saying
there could be 20 different endings and
many of them are quite thrilling sure I
do however agree with Hikaru that it
does happen that when your opponent duh
start to split slip apart when your
opponent does slip mistakes often come
in pairs or even worse you know you just
get on the wrong horse and you keep
writing it to dilute and so if you have
slipped with h3 there you your opponent
expects you will slip again and again
and again and that's you that's how you
lose you you you
you you get the wrong concepts or the
ideas and it's my ecology though that
you're saying like no it's just
practical I mean you have the wrong idea
and you stick with wrong exactly exactly
you you see something in the position
that has caught your fancy I'm winning
an exchange and you do the only problem
is that's not the key factor the key
factor is your open King but you want in
the exchange for are you trapped the
guy's piece and you won the piece but
oops you you left yourself an open goal
net um you have a problem I'm sorry
please that position you got on the
board yes please the h3 move but when
someone's attacking your king
yes if you know we see this happen in
the King's Indian all the time
white plays this idea of f3 sometimes h3
then puts he has a [ __ ] money too he
puts a knight on f2 and everybody stops
g4 like you are never playing g4 for all
of eternity against me right everybody
stops the move g4 right and the like
square Bishop features very highly in
that position particularly for black
now witness move h3 White has slowed
down g4 but has he stopped g4 well you
make a couple of moves like in the lines
you're talking about Queens ee8 rook to
e1 Queen g6
in that position where we're looking at
moves for white like blacks not starting
to threaten stuff black is threatening
g4 now and so quiet move you better be
ready to calculate if you're plating the
move Knight c4 because g4 is coming and
he's going to open up that side and what
do you do in fact like nicéphore g4 what
do you do
the engines giving Queen f2 are you
happy now I mean it's like yeah it's
like what's no no I'm against nicephore
94g for it I see so that happened but
without the work e1 I believe is this
position I maybe have that on the board
now nice boy 94 Queens you think all
right so now the move now the move g4 is
is on tap what's your next move what's
your next best
ceefor was playing 94 was play queen g6
was not not rook d6 played I think in
the very beginning isn't White's still a
little better here with the better
Bishop I mean you don't think the dark
square pond down you've got a passer
this open open diagonal very very
compelling no no no I do appreciate that
open bag no for white not so easy to get
your Queen on this battery by the way
but I do see what makes me fix Queen
takes a fix on the board followed by h4
whoa I didn't see that well obviously
he's hoping that he will be able to yes
exploit allow for some end games after
Jaipur the transpose into the end game
after Queen takes off for I have no idea
do you take stage for Queen takes up for
does white have a lot of comp in that
end game because the weekend H pawn and
that the deep on well I'm seeing really
double-edged ideas like Bishop here
ideas of Queen c5 check I'm wondering
who has the initiative and why this
Bishop strikes me as a very good Bishop
as does the bishop on on c3 c5 c4 is
just a plain old honoree I want to count
her attack
I still haven't fully understood the
repercussions of h6 yet
what about c4 just play to be queen f2
just trying to directly get on the
diagonal and meet you
before you have time to fight back
exactly exactly I guess you could play
rook c8 so that Queen d4 could be met
with Queen c5 to trade Queens
yeah worried about like a Bishop landing
on f6 after I take you and g5 exactly we
should let our viewers see some of that
analysis right so c4 Queen oh well no
I've helped I've helped white set up a
battery I know but but let's just show
the movie port Queen up to now it's
showing up so my idea it wasn't showing
up for some reason it wasn't yes c14 f2
rook c8 because we've got to get Queen
c5 in and then we were saying that after
Queen D for Queen c5 you get what you
want but is it enough I'm pleased and c5
is playable there why can bishops queen
c5 and Bishop the mission b4 is dropping
what so that's just better than whites
just great then white is wonderful you
just went in exchange and I don't think
I don't see any other way to play except
for Rick c8 because Queen d4 is a real
devastating threat yeah I know my C 5 c4
was asking maybe feels weird yeah I
would stay away from this I would stay
away from C 5 C 4 C right now it's hard
for white to get his Queen on this
diagonal long diagonal to for the
checkmate so first of all what is wrong
with h6
your fabbi obviously is trying to break
up the team on the Kings side and Queen
h8 Shaq is not devastating I mean Queen
h8 but is not it has not ended the game
with a checkmate or something like that
this reminds me of something though this
reminds me of so what this reminds me of
Fabiano Caruana versus chakra our
manager of in Batumi just a
a month ago the Olympia Olympia but even
better okay Mike this position you just
described because after Queen e5 in this
position he has a lot more pieces on in
that game he only had a queen and a rook
on but the idea of just harassing the
king the King never had security and he
just bothered it and bothered it and
bought and just kept harassing it and
finally the guy cracked and then he just
pummeled him that was a great game by
the way a big game against Azerbaijan
and in this position
Fabi would dream about having because
the Queen expose King opposite color
bishops passed pawn this would be you be
back in business in this position no
question about it I mean he's gonna
start torturing you this thread is on
the board your king is forever exposed
it's not a win right now it's not that
kind of position but boy it's looking
really difficult in here and don't
forget this move is coming so he can
just go for material and you may not
lose by mate but you're gonna suffer
just just continue like rook eh look I
mean be a create you give me a check
I'll go back to g8 you can go take on
c500 you want to do this worse okay I
was thinking rookie - I won't give you
any well you know what you figure this
one out okay D pawn is fast
okay rookie - rookie - what what I want
to go Bishop efore this is a move that
stops you all the time right okay I'm
gonna try - Queen really at least a perp
don't with the things it takes G - G -
you had a surprising one oh yeah yeah
yeah four check sorry to interrupt
ourselves but we do have a phone call
from
New York do we still have a phone call
from the US do we still have them yeah
so right in the middle well on the
pitched battle you want to [ __ ] off from
New York well I can't be about this pawn
becoming a queen on the next move I'm
not gonna be happy cuz this is a sharp
stuff and I'm sure our fans want to know
about this and then a question on the
phone okay
we will give an eye on the live board as
well because this game is just really
opening up right now in the last hour as
well I think Magnus is taking the pause
just a quick question from you and we
will keep an eye on the game while we
get take your question okay so it
doesn't seem like they're there anymore
but that of course is analysis let's
keep her an eye on the analysis and the
live board as h4 you said that Magnus
has taken on a chore no no I thought you
said that so yes but I think he wants to
age members are last moving the board
and we're wondering is Magnus gonna try
to play eight six if he takes on H fours
maurices uh is reckoning
what's the line here is there a way for
us to keep Queens on the board yes
because you know it just it looks like
the Queen trade is not exactly what
White has been playing for right so what
else can we do after G takes h4 can we
play for Queen h5 there or is Queen g6
just gonna delay the inevitable I don't
know aren't you afraid of your of your
king like yeah that's why I'm wondering
if I might just have to play Queen takes
f4 and and reckon with the fact that I'm
gonna win your h4 upon I have a better
Bishop still maybe I can still claim
something but I I just want to say like
is there a way for us to keep the ladies
on the board
is there something with rook e1 perhaps
idea of rookie six are you just gonna
play rook e8
well rook e1 I definitely see Bishop e5
exactly it has a chance to secure in
exchange and I probably have to play
rook e8 just as you're suggesting and
then if I take twice and play Queen h5
again you can just stick something on g6
but you want to take a look at that sure
okay so from the starting position you
reckon that that Magnus should take
age for what if he does okay I'm looking
for ways to keep the Queens on the board
rather than Queen takes that for which
is kind of what it seems like magnets
once right
okay so rook takes rook takes Queen h5
so you reckon this would be the
consequent I think the problem is Queens
you six again and good attacking move
good defensive moves that's the price I
have to stop Queen takes ei you
mentioned this I mean this your scare
for right now
well this play instead of so I Pleakley
h5 forcing you to play queen g6 and if I
take yes if I take it's just not the
pawns not so fast that you're well
you've sacrificed two pawns and I'm not
saying you don't have compensation but
you are definitely better before you
went into this yeah loin high because
you can always block it with Bishop e7
right yeah that's a good that's a good
starting move right now I'm not a
hundred percent sure you have a threat I
was gonna play Bishop f6 I thought but
that's not a threat either right so if
you want to play d7 I'll go good then so
is there any way to keep Queens on the
board or after takes on eight tours my
best play is white to simply play Queen
takes out four
let's take a look at that is that is
that anything for white to write home
about
well I as white I would be very very
happy to get rid of this f4 pawn as a as
I feel that's the most threatening pawn
and black will have no choice but to
trade Queens right because you're not
going to you're not going to countenance
the battery with the Queen on e5 so
let's just imagine take stakes I feeling
that this is spinning towards a draw I
don't know should I play h3 by the way
or should I just you
thank you my grade on h4 is it I mean
you're not it's not but when you play h3
you're trying to like keep the pond
right yeah well I'm a palm grabber so
you should expect that I could try to
keep up on grabber and up on keeper yeah
well yeah
harvest and keep um and then d6 I run
away with a pond now what because now
Bishop d7 bishops of opposite colors
right and good yeah seven is just a good
block ad move but what about the 57 then
I take on h3
whatever why do I have to block a this
poem why can't I just take on G - you're
saying if d7 you just have rook ta but
then maybe I have some tactics yeah - oh
I was thinking instead just playing d7
here and then I was wondering if I had
some tactics with like I want to try to
like get my Bishop on it take on f5 and
get Bishop f6 in but it's not quite
working is it nearly worked defy like
after 55 is good 45 whoa it's blacks
move after D so brooksy85 you can't take
with the rook because a bishops hanging
and if you take with the bishop so
that's winning yeah Bishop g6 would be
forced with any take on that thing and
Bishop f6 that's what I was trying to
get that bishop to have sex yeah so that
means that after her after d6 he did
take on h4 by the way after this did
Magnus Magnusson so is there still some
poison in that variation then after
Queen f4 after Queen F word takes an F
for h3 this d6 move maybe you have to
blockade rather than take 1 G 2 so H 3
d6 maybe you have to play Bishop d7 but
then I get to take on h3 myself yeah I'm
thinking that in a bishop well first of
all I'm not really sure
what I'm playing for is black if I'm h3
I'm trying to play for an advantage
right yeah clear keep your pond I try to
keep my pond keeper rook b8 going to
make a draw and trade pieces right so
I'm not exactly sure who's playing for
advantage after Queen f4 looking for
looked I was I was thinking that was why
you could still try to like push this
initiative and calculate the lines with
me six right okay so assuming this is
the breakaway pawn and the most
dangerous pawn in the position let's
assume I'm playing for a draw and a
blockade of your passer now after d6
you're just gonna stick your Bishop on
d7 something like that right to just
where is my best Square it's not that
easy the Bishop Bishop f6 is coming if
you if you move your Bishop right Bishop
so if I move my bishop you you'll drop
your bishop inside my position as a
second hmm okay so do I have to play
something a little bit awkward like this
then and then now if you play these six
let's go okay so I want to play Bishop
d7 and Bishop c6 and in this case I'm
trying to blockade the pawn and now if I
take and play d7 you have 48 I don't
have the six square anymore right okay
so what do you have against rook d5
we've been talking about yeah hanging to
make me best tend to end the game ooks
and rook and d7 is a threatened on it
looks like yeah well Bishop e6 you mean
you you play what you play with a step 7
no the King comes in the game yeah you
don't have time 47 I just take your rook
and just a trade
it could be lose your valuable pond
exactly that wasn't you you get out of
Dodge and f7 again but
four has been playing can you change the
position in that position so Queen takes
that four on the board maggie has gone
for the Queen trade so rook takes that
four were thinking after rook F for ff7
maybe that's not the best move maybe I
have to just drop back with my bishop
immediately Bishop d7 I'm a visual of
six and if Bishop f6 I still don't quite
have the Zen of the position still a
black should be able to hold on well the
other positions were really much more
scary when you were yeah your queen on
h6 and you look on east oh for sure I
really felt that fabbi
you know it was throwing the paddies
here it feels like Black has a lot of
defensive resource and he put a
beautiful move what did much better move
it that then the ones where some Queen
takes f4 it was played takes the move h5
okay that looks like a very very fun Oh
take a bishop on g4 put a bishop on g4
display and you know I guess if you
could ever force the trade of rooks and
allow for King f7 that would be a very
easy way to shut down here comes the art
of defense by the best player on the
planet yeah and this is one of the
problems we see when you don't play the
best moves and really prosecute your
advantage
defense starts to take hold and we have
a completely different kind of game and
now instead of it being just a clean win
it looks like now fabi's let this slip
his h3 was one tempo too slow and rook a
d1 wasn't the most precise move but that
was forgivable but 86 h3 was not in the
movie wanted to play and now we see why
you may see miss just one move and
that's it and unfortunately this is
looking more and more not just because
I'm gonna be Fabi fans but just in
general as chess fans to see 8 straight
draws to start a world championship
that's a record that ties the record in
fact of the game we talked about the
match we talked about I'm not
just as far of in 1995 that will tie the
record with eight straight draws and
it's really looking like we will get a
tie now and doesn't mean we're gonna
have nine straight break the record in
any match to start a world championship
match they're so close you you have to
take chances
I gotta give him credit yc5 he just
didn't find the most incisive way to get
answer with his pawn sacrifice he played
a little bit too close to the vest with
his moves open Sicilian not only did he
play c5 just his opening choice worked
out so brilliantly and it's it's kind of
sad for Bobby fans if he doesn't manage
to squeeze anything out of this position
I mean I don't even know if he's better
but that said if if he doesn't end up
winning this game it's really sad
because it was like the perfect
situation he got he kind of picked
Magnus with the information about it
does an on-set got a massive edge on the
clock great position and Magnus was was
must have been terrified I mean knowing
that carefully obviously right and the
slip up because f4 and g5 you Magnus did
not force
fabbi to play a move like b4 or rook a
four so fabbi got everything he wanted
and he spoiled it with this one bad move
Age 3 you know kind of forcefully
reminds the game 3 I believe where he
played bishop on c1 to d2
instead of rook takes a5 and in the post
match press conference that we just said
you know one bad move and I spoiled
everything
and it's really remarkable that this
move h2 h3 it doesn't even feel that bad
and move it's not that but you make lift
tempo and shampo tempo in sharp
positions yeah you know this is not a
slow block position where you can say
the guy can't do anything at all he has
no moves I've got the luxury I love you
guys I'm gonna improve over here and a
bit there and play no in sharp positions
timing is everything right and when you
wait the guy find something to do and
suddenly you're looking you say what
happens
my advantage and that's exactly what
happened here we have an semi-open
toward open position and two bishops and
queen and dynamic possibilities and you
don't have the luxury of playing this
kind of waiting move and he played h3
waited a little too long
Magnus found of course this idea of
Queen e8 with the Queen going to g6 and
that's all she wrote
that was it all of a sudden the game
just transformed itself and Fabi had to
hurry up and play this idea that he
played instead of allowing black to get
the counter play with g4 exploiting to
move h3 as a matter of fact nice so just
poor timing on his part one quiet move
and I'll add you gen you mentioned the
right opening the information advantage
let's add time on the clock yeah that
was huge it was massive time advantage
exactly it was it was it was in so much
trouble and not to liquidate it to an
end game where you can just show off his
incredible in-game virtuosity that's not
what you wanted and I'm boldly gonna
make a prediction that I don't think
this means fabi's how to condenser for
the match not at all but I'd boldly
predict that Magnus is gonna put the
Sicilian to rest after this game I think
next time probably plays e4 Magnus is
gonna play e5 I feel like the Sicilian
was a quasi Bluff you know I know the
open Sicilian lions are the most testing
so while you play this raw sleemo that I
feel like blacks good I'll keep playing
it as soon as you play the open I'm
gonna write a missed opportunity big big
big time that's my feeling because I
really you know I don't really did I
don't think you want because who knows I
have a couple things he might just go
for double king fun especially because a
lot of the postulating that we've had
about how Fabi Maggie doesn't mind
seeing a tiebreaker that said Fabiano's
team could have something really great
prepared against double king pandu
because that was their main preparation
could you put their move h5 to the test
for me Maurice why why do we think that
this move is such a great defensive move
assuming d6 right with a similar idea of
rook d5
followed by rook g5 how would the line
go why why is Maggie shutting down the
position Bishop g4 mm-hmm you're
attacking my rook so I assume I have to
take on f8 right and I assume I have to
play rook to d5 you're attacking my rook
on d1 and I can put my Bishop on e7
perhaps yeah this just dad draw or
something okay I think this is where
Jennifer was hitting me with a Bishop f6
and a d6 d7 idea
aha okay so I don't have time for d7 and
that's a rook and pawn attending I'm
already up a pawn so be careful well
your extra pawn is a double H bond dude
so I'm saying but it's so if you're
trying to do something you're not you're
just liquidating down if you play d7
it's to liquidate down into a draw an
endgame right sorry I'm just analyzing
d7 Bishop d7 rook d7 King f6 rip b7 and
aren't I playing rook b6 check takes a
six I thought it was better but maybe
it's still a bad draw or something but a
little bit better for fabbi I can't
imagine I'm having trouble imagining it
too but okay I mean first of all I I
don't know if I play this move the isn't
if I played this and you wanted to argue
that this position is winning I wouldn't
make that I wouldn't bet my life behind
the pawn to rook those behind the throne
yeah okay but okay go back to when we
had bishops on the board because you did
something and I could have played Bishop
takes h4 I think where you putting your
your you've got time to blockade on d7
no very good then it's just
rook c8 was a a very good move rook c8
was a very good it's hard to believe I
mean now you look at the position and
you can feel the draw coming ya feel it
it's not there no there no points the
punch the punch at really in the bunker
it just looks like black is in a
solidifying position and we're gonna
have a pity one where opposite color
position obstacle and bishops can
definitely show great attacking chances
but here until you until you show that
attacking chance you got zip blaine
woody what are you gonna do you're a
deep on optically is not just optically
it is potentially very powerful very
potent if only the guy could just give
you his LightSquared bishop so that you
could keep pushing but here it's just
negatory h5 is a really good move a
really good move
lifting the mate threats by the way
although Macey was worried about is gone
are gone bishop will go to g4 with the
tempo trade trade rooks bring the King
closer this is Magnus we are talking
Magnus Carlsen right you you can keep
looking
you're not going to trick him here
superb move no question about it
Jen and another swing and a Miss I mean
we've seen a lot of swings and misses in
this match as you have to not only do
you have to play really really well but
the precision required is on a great
level in accuracy well we've had a
couple mistakes in this game but no
blunders that's for sure I mean we made
the mistake for Fabi being h3 and the
mistake for Magnus being the original
concept with g5 but then no blunders in
the magics of games that's right
I mean Game one and the only blunder and
that was Magnus right so we were
thinking of inaccuracies which were
moves that cost you four tenths of a
pawn or by the engine or mass then we
were thinking in terms of mistakes those
moves that cost you a point shift there
was that for sure
there was a there was that yesterday was
that and
the blunder which is greater than a one
and a half point switch they might have
been a huge swing where the game here
you know this is added up maybe if they
add up rook d1 nh3 if you add up the net
effect of the reduction of advantage
you'd say those two moves really put put
away White's hopes of getting a mess do
you think is it possible to miss this
maneuver Queen e8 to g6 because like
that seems like maybe you thought he had
a little bit more time just chill h3 and
I'll play you know one of my suspicions
says no doubts about it he looked at
Queen age five he probably got to some
position like this in his mind's eye and
he said why am I trying to achieve this
without really making a judgment as to
what is my opponent's next move going to
be you know this east six where the
rooks of great whites rooks all of that
right yeah I mean but then you're
switching after Bishop d6 you're
switching to well I'm just I'm just
chill you know no problem right but that
might be the move like Queen after me
it's like weird to play for Queen h3
it's like a triangulation of the Queen
you see that I don't know it's a very
strange one but and it's it but it
really is like exactly here where the
move h2 h3 really does and it it doesn't
look like that bad of move I mean if I
saw this without really just I was
flashing through the game and replaying
the game and somebody played h3
I wouldn't have my hair stand up and go
oh my gosh what a mistake something in
between the two moves like suppose just
look on f2 on like that's a kind of
logical looking move isn't
right before and created for and that's
and if you're keen f2 there's g3 now
yeah yeah now the problem is you can
really make yourself actually quite
afraid that you've allowed your
opponents right yeah we're in the other
lines or Bishop when we play brick de
wad or your your Bishop wasn't on d6 yet
so the character of the position was a
little different that's a great g4
because I could take her out for a lot
of the times yeah and queen h5 is just
sidestepping this g4 counter-attacking
business and I think guys okay yeah up
here in the position on the right update
us after h5 what was played rook e1 e1
and then came mr. g4 okay threatening
the rook rook f6 rook f6 okay and our
King tree and that's my right rook takes
and Bishop takes so we're up to date so
I mean he still fabbi still has dreams
of dreams hopes and dreams of playing
Bishop takes h4 d6 and rookie seven that
would be a dream position for four white
together works can come over the board
very easily here camp seven ever key
eight look like
well once again you're being a party
pooper why I guess I can play rook f1 I
want to I want to just keep on but only
because I'm trying to I'm being stubborn
kg6 and d6 well here I would rather have
the white pieces for sure because I've
got the most important pawn in the
position but can can to Magnus do a
little bit better than that so this is
the current position yes huh okay he has
no time for rook d8 and ripped because
the bishop now covers the d8 square
does it make sense
can I try to maintain the pollen on the
King side with h3 rookie 7 can i play
this or should I take on g2 first I
don't know I want to play rook d8 you
can't da can I I want to shake I go here
I take your bishop oh I see okay so I
take on g2 you take on g2 right no d6
whoa you're trying to I mean I get d7
you're just you're asking me to win
d7 I I'm not asking you to win I don't
want you to win
no I oops I have d7 again don't can i
play Bishop okay so what was happening I
work g7 check sorry what you I'm trying
to find a way to win
yeah you don't have a threat do you need
to play rook takes f6
okay so Bishop c3 ah just stepping off
the diagonal that looks great yeah okay
okay for some reason I had it in my mind
that I had this very big threat a rook F
on Shaq and it's not a big threat at all
you need a bit of a dream of all it is
so we're expecting King of 7 don't let
that rogue get on 87 that's it yeah
we're expecting this move king of 7
Bishop h4 rookie a rookie f1 and now
your buddy King on g6 which gives you
this rook have 6 temple later why can't
I play King g8 I'll just back up I
should be putting my rook obviously
behind the past pawn was something like
rookie 5 or or even e2
really harassing - D - yeah because I
can also play Bishop d7 Bishop c6 la
cane and counter-attack on a good day
you get your rook on the seventh second
rank yeah then you put your Bishop on c6
842 pawn starts to move down the board
fair enough I mean this error enough
this is way too drunk way to drawn what
desired social media world reckoned was
it a huge miss this h3 move yeah I mean
Jerry said it's a draw now I'm Nicolas
soutien booth Beth who has been tweeting
about the match pretty frequently said
that he actually had this exact
preparation on his chest base file what
she shared I guess no point to keeping
it secret anymore
Wow so he was like I felt really proud
my appropriation to France apparently
wasn't to that nice yeah good one
Costa Kazuki says that he was really
thrilled by Peter that goes commentary
in this fashion at gob and do you but it
what perfect timing
Andreea rostering says she really likes
the current position of the eighth game
I also saw her tweet earlier if anyone
was covering the Women's World
Championship while the championship was
going on and the answer is yes we are
talking about the Women's World
Championship everyday so tune in to
today and chess for that and Maurice
speaking of the Women's World
Championship today's game you've got it
up on the board yeah you were tweeting
because I wanted to say there was
another miss as well in the Women's
World Championship as soon as you guys
started talking what a Miss I was like
let's get to that game because Katarina
like know what the black pieces could
have won this game if she had found the
right moves but it was a dogfight Bishop
e3 queen bee - ooh engine with white
currently
white is even materially but under
pressure as this pawn was captured 92
and Bishop eight six and you see black
is trying all kinds of tricks 95 is a
threat now because both pawns are pinned
Bishop f2
g5 talk about a dynamic aggressive game
this move g5 rook me 1 and now Queen a3
Queen to b3 looking to trade queen she
says uh uh
let's keep it going G takes G takes and
rook f8 neither King castling you want
to talk about asymmetric pawn formation
pressure on the B line weak east six
pawn
she got terrified of the idea of Queen
e6 in this position actually a good move
for her instead she played Queen f3 and
allowed Queen takes a two and now this
move King to g2 and he or she had a
really good chance you talk about a Miss
the move ruck GA check would have been
very strong here notice the Queen is
pinning across this line and the D pawn
is hanging your king goes to h3 in
southern new of Queen c2 could have been
played with Queen f5 check and a black
is in business in this position this is
how she could have really put the
pressure on white and probably won the
game I don't know if she was any time
pressure over because after King to g2
she immediately shut everything down
with Queen d5 offering a queen exchange
which our opponent gladly accepted and
went into this end game and now with a
lot less on the board she took rook C
798 rook a7 and they very quickly I'm
going to jump to the final position got
to this one repeating moves and the game
ended in a draw so a moment here as well
missed opportunity for black she'll be
back in her hotel room will Katarina
thinking man I could have hunted her
down
Fabiano is gonna be feeling the same way
today that is a challenger could have
defeated a champion in this game and
Fabi the Challenger could have defeated
a champion as well so we see in both
both championship matches the Challenger
did not rise to the occasion and let the
champion off the hook coulda woulda
shoulda huh how it goes back to back
those near misses especially with the
black pieces Jennifer I mean that's what
we always thought that having the white
pieces is such a great advantage this
match is proven that not to be the case
tomorrow
exactly okay so we are in this position
and we are expecting the world champion
to play the move king f7 returning this
pond on h4 in order to get his rook
activated remember those whole game this
rook on b8 has basically been a
spectator to the proceedings any rook
trade would precipitate an easy draw so
we would anticipate fabbi retaining the
rooks and then after move like d6
dropping his rook into the second rank
and getting ready to defend with Bishop
d7 to c6 and the reckoning is a draw is
inevitable thanks to the active black
rook in this case yeah what's your take
on how this affects the match going
forward Bobby is so cool ice water in
his veins as we saw on the ice bucket
challenge that he executed right before
he went 700 at the think he'll Cup but
at the same time this must be a little
annoying right getting such a great
it's an unusual type of chest
disappointment right because it's a
combination of things
exactly you didn't lose the game you
didn't lose a game you have two white
left out of the next four so it's not
like all the news is negative but you do
feel like you lost something like a
missed a missed miss another clean out
your system right now given that you had
such a great chance
I mean gearing up you played c5 you put
all that time thinking about c5 gearing
up to be aggressive only to fall back
and be passive and play the move h3 to
stop what look like black creating some
energy missing the move Queen h5 and I
think ramnik said it best Kramnik said
it looks like he's not quite off on like
that kind of phone you need you're
playing against a world champion you
need that kind of form and you got to
put it together from the opening to the
middle game to the endgame it's not
enough to just get a good position
everybody gets good positions it happens
to everyone you can get a good position
congratulations
can you prosecute your advantage from
opening
middlegame endgame that's how the game
is played in all three phases and he
didn't show it this game I really feel
like okay hardening the metaphor but in
some ways Pappy had really hooked his
fish he had finally caught Magnus out
he's just kind of getting the net ready
to bring the fish in you know and just
this let it slip in he got away just
like that and it would it just amazes me
that it it shifted so dramatically on a
move that really didn't look that bad
that move h3 I agree it it's soft but
when you're in white shoes and you're
seeing g4 and you're seeing Queen h4 h3
you could somehow convince yourself it's
okay and I still keep I've got all the
advantages still pertinent in the
position and then just perfect play by
Magnus and he's out he's out of the
woods again perfect play yeah after the
move h3 but it was a perfect play it was
just Queen e8 queen g6 there was there
was nothing else it wasn't anything well
he had to do just Queen e8 Queen g6
right I'm here he had yet course boy the
end game but I mean din I mean the
middle game yet to avoid the middle game
H 5 H 5 was a great move but not an S or
it was a it was a great move but it
wasn't a necessary move mean these I
mean the only few moves got played let's
not overstate it's not like ok the most
attack killer amazing look at that
sequence you just have to find Queen e8
Queen g6 and then the rest were well
within anybody's tolerance right so once
he newts or Queenie 8 which by the way I
would say you know everybody more yeah
all the way down the rating scale
there's a lot of ways down a rating
scale that would say yeah I want to get
my Queen in the game now let me switch
it get it over to g6 and boom right so
it's not like it's not like Magnus
suddenly played like a hyper genius to
save himself he's not like oh my god he
had to do some some kind of Keanu Reeves
matrix right bullets
and maybe stop the bullets doing my
thing game six right you didn't have to
do any of that to save this game he just
had to find Queenie like what's wrong
with Queenie and just you know make some
moves and boom a woman you got zip and
it was fast
it was really fast by the way only about
six or seven moves in Sunday's positions
equal so no this is Fabiano slip this is
not Magnus providing any kind of
spectacular genius ideas he played got
himself in a very bad position and Bobby
let him off the hook
agreed rook e8 by the way rook f1 on the
board
as expected the players are going down
our drawing line we are now expecting
the move King g8 to be played and it
looks like well a straight draw and that
ties off to that move with Queen h5
how's that like awesome Queen I like to
call it Queen try a triangulation mmm
after Bishop takes Queen eight six rook
at seven the line that you took us
through several times right this is
where wherever you did it because you
thought that this looks like white made
no progress right right and then closer
examination it was sort of like is this
triangle triangulation what did I do
feels that way because like the Queen's
I guess it to me yeah and then you put
your Queen on f3 and now it's like c4 is
not possible actually like I pushed her
pieces back somehow
right this baby went backwards this
Bishop went backwards White's rooks took
up central files and diamond but if you
look at the path of the Queen in the
last few moves it is a little weird like
an unusual pattern right like the bishop
the Queen going absolutely we going from
h3 I mean from everything to here
yeah backs it back to there to here all
the way back to yeah and I wonder if
that's like part of it like that
I am sure Bobby would appreciate all of
the how great white was in the final
position but
this is so unusual maybe it escaped
mm-hmm
I think I think I don't think it ice you
know escaped it might not be the right
way I think he might have even seen it
and thought what this is ridiculous my
Queens getting chased like what right
have I achieved have I have I
successfully improved my position right
and perhaps he judged that he had not
but you know just again if he had just
stopped and thought about well in fact
he had this rook on f1 coming to e1 and
then to e6 is a real accomplishment but
the only thing he gained was rook e1
that's the funny part but the bishops
are pushed back - I know but what's
funny is what black rearranges pieces ro
put his Bishop on f8 you got all those
boobs in that diagram you're showing
there right and all you got is rookie
all I got was Ricky one yeah you guys
like I had to get all those boobs he
must have done something wildly while I
was doing all the rights that he go well
you got all those moves but they don't
count for anything
they really don't think yeah the rook
I'm b8 is terrible the Queen on d8
hasn't moved and so what you've got the
rook on f7 that might be a reasonably
improvement but none of the other pieces
and you're still facing d5 it's
hilarious
that's probably why he missed h3 I think
of anything he saw his queen getting
chase chase chase chase a judge or like
you know what I don't want my queen to
get chased let me just stop that right
one he had a narrow path to having a
better position it's not right so it's
funny that work do you want even if
technically compared to the computer
engines it wasn't a much what worse move
practically speaking it turns out to be
a much worse not sure if you put the
rook anyone did you have to be so razor
precise to get a good one stopping all
that bouncing that's right that's right
Wow so we're about to see by the way a
repeat of
by the way just to make this point so
rook d1 Bishop d6 I remember a variation
that ran for d1 Bishop d6 Queen h5 all
right Queen h5 I'm sorry yes please
three h5 Queen EA in this position
uh-huh okay
Queen g5 check that is a pardon queen g6
okay and you've gotten your pawn back as
why yes with a clearly much better
position than you than you had in the
game and also you can start working him
in this wasn't but it's not it's not
Auto over well I mean if you were to
make a comparison between this ending
you could take with the pond and the
game itself I'm a big favorite to now
take and put my Bishop on f4 pardon me
pick up your pawn on f4 right so I will
I've already won one pawn back I won
your pawn on d5 but now I'm about to go
upon ahead and I'll still have the most
important passer in the position right
no I'm not disagreeing with you oh yeah
yeah being better I'm just saying the
Queen e8 music keeps creeping in right
even if you want to play Queen age five
us pop and look at that wrong but if you
put the wrong on anyone there are no
manoeuvres no Queen e8 right and you're
just you're just crying over there
that's right creating allowing this
position to happen that's right one was
off any mistakes came in pairs as you
said exactly again we're gonna refresh
it will probably take a very short break
a shorter break we're gonna be in Harvin
at the points here and mastership can I
show you something else as well
look just following this line rook to e1
this is how bad it is Bishop d6 Queen h5
if you try that same nonsense like
before okay Queen h6 threatening mate
you guard the mate rookie six and you
resigned right there's a maid of a
change sign because rook g6 is coming
and yeah you know a bishop f8 you just
resigned
that's how active the Brooklyn
was exactly and Brooke D 1 was not rooks
belong oh wow yeah it has had a
completely crushing position with this
game would have been over already
basically that's how bad the advantage
it was huge advantage white black would
have to scramble to try to figure out
what to do as this position proceeded
because rook on e1 and it's just like oh
oh
give me the numerical slips there please
Maurice well rook e1 was favored by how
many tenths of a pond over rook t1 well
I'll tell you Ricky won the our engine
is not as strong as ceci correct ceci
was up / - Wow right especially was up
over to with the move rook to work a e1
okay was just like you're gonna die two
points oh oh yes correct
you're gonna just die in this position
now this engine took a while to catch up
to set C's assessment okay so it might
take some time for it to really find out
so I don't think I'm going to give you a
fair answer just on the fly but this one
right now is giving a point seven
advantage to this move and giving a
point three it looks like advantage it's
up there as well 4/10 of the palm it's
actually liking this move just as
equally as it likes Ricky one look at
that not even looking is as I were
looking or oh now it's dropping and I
was dropping and saying not nearly as
much of an advantage so it takes some
time for the engine to catch up and look
at all the variations to run like the
supercomputer ceci which is looking at
this position on every single move and
found that mate in 36 for example
because it's it's so sharp when this
engine did not see the mate at all right
so and that is which engine you're using
and then the next point was Bishop d6
now now when you go to h3 you see the
you see the barometer drop like
dramatically okay if you put plane h5 on
people drive on the board it stays where
it is so I like our language in is like
one point oh oh no no it's though it's
no point point eight point eight point
seven there abouts the ice no no it's
not one point yeah
it's still there work on d1 you're
talking about yeah I'm talking with the
rook on d1 so H remember why it's not
getting that same position anymore the
move Queen e8 now
Queenie a we talked about this line all
right we need Queen g6 taste takes you
one is way Knight to c4 in this position
Brooke d8 giving you this pawn back by
trying to make some blockade of this
pawn getting some one of those kind of
end games you do have something to play
for but it's starting to look more and
more tenacious possibilities for defense
so okay this you should not a play like
this yes should not a play like this
adds rook e1 would have been a smashing
victory consistent with the move c5
would have been just smashing just
amazing now opportunity lost
okay by the way we before we do go on
break we do see the move rook after king
g8 as expected by Magnus we're not
seeing this move d6 we just saw instead
rook on F 1 2 F 6 the idea of Fabiano is
that he's going to swing his rook I
believe over to b6 which would protect
the pawn on b2 while activating the rook
and threatening earth takes b7 I think
that black is out of the woods after it
moved like Bishop C 8 or even Rupp D to
the game I continue testing the waters a
little bit he certainly could have and
we're back with after a quick break to
see how it shakes out
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. Chess
Championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online to more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
Chess Club is highly engaged with the
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
Chess Club is the world chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of faith cutting-edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the world chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to today in chess
world championship edition we have three
and a half three happen hey wait it's
actually four four as the game between
Fabiano carolina which looked so
promising for the american challenger
has been drawn in this bishops of
opposite color and game with one rook
for each side yes what an incredible
start to the game for Fabi and what a
disappointment yeah I mean lost but well
he always had the big edge he always had
because we went in today and I tell you
here on set I don't know what it was but
there was this feeling in the air that
was that magical like today was a day we
all felt it there was a special energy
on the set and we thought it was going
to be decisive we 100% sure who was
gonna win but we thought this was going
to be the decisive game and it looked
like it could have been what could have
been turned into a woulda coulda shoulda
h2 h3 fabbi threw away a very large
advantage let Magnus escape and now
we're are in the history books of eight
consecutive draws tying a record that
was established in 1995 between Garry
Kasparov and Vishwanath on to none
Louise you were there to call that
action as I was I was and the folks were
clamoring for a victory they were not
happy with all those drawers there's
some kind of Records you don't want to
break right this is one of those records
you don't want to break the record of
starting a world the record low
fertility for starting a world
championship match and so far eight
straight draws tying now on on versus
Kasparov and I'm sure I Nauticus bar
over like yeah hurry up and draw this
one so that we can be removed right from
the history books for that match just
crazy first of all there would have been
any question of the record if magnets
are just one game one right there would
have been like many matches before no
record because we just win right away
well at least a record for no food
dylaney then the opportunity came to
Fabi in that epic game six where he had
the made in 36 but everybody agrees he
would have been checked for some kind of
device if he had found that sequence so
that one he can be forgiven for he can
say and he brushed it he said you know
rusted offices you know what it was like
a lucky moment accidental win if you
will right he will not have that excuse
today be curious to see what he says
about this one because this was no
accident folks this was just a straight
screw-up he should have put the pedal to
the metal and run Magnus crossing over
but instead he played a couple of tepid
moves rook a d1 was first instead of
rook a e1 and then this was h3 and then
it just all went up in smoke after
Queenie a queen g6 and that was that and
it wasn't like Magnus did anything super
genius he just found a couple of good
moves and got to his endgame and drew
the game so as much as we're fans of
Fabi and it seemed Fabi in the building
but we got to call it like we see it
this was a slip today by Fabiano Caruana
no question Thank You Maurice and
definitely Jennifer I thought it was
great preparation by Fabi
how big a time edge do we think that
babby had at one time because you told
me after 18 moves he had gained time on
the clock very significant so at least
up to 38 minutes at some point it is
hard to I mean I obviously it's very
disappointing as a Fabi fantasy how do
they went down but there's also positive
way to look at it am I not surprised
that you're gonna go okay let's go
you're the lobbyist let's tell it I mean
yes in many games he's out preparing he
does and that bodes well and I like the
idea that he is scaring Magnus off
potentially Sicilian and forcing him
perhaps into a territory that team
Papi's prepared even more let's hope so
for that so
for the next couple white games III
think that we're gonna break the trend
and there's gonna be something for why
here's the schedule that's remaining
this for games Jennifer we will be
playing on Thanksgiving on Thanksgiving
car deewana will be white but it's game
game 9 tomorrow will be a free day that
Carlson will be starting with the white
pieces November 21st that's right
have white with with magnets on
Wednesday and then Thanksgiving it's
gonna be a big day as Bobby's gonna get
another crack with the white pieces
right and that's where we both agree
that we may not be seeing an open
society I think so that 'if I've that
this Magnus is not going to be very
pleased with what happened and the
preparation was so great shall I say
turkey right I got enough but let me
just say today was opportunity missed
and this is not what you want to do in a
World Championship match he had Magnus
dead to all rights
better preparation time on the clock
absolutely winning position just a
devastating position after you played
the great move c5 and then he hesitated
if you want to win the world
championship match you want to take it
away from the guy with a crown you've
got to kick him when he's down you've
got to get it done and today Fabi did
not get it done and now he's gonna have
to face the psychological impact of
knowing that he had this great position
that it was basically an easy win I mean
it was it was gonna be huge look let's
not even making a fine point about it
Ruka e1 and Magnus would have been in
deep deep trouble
and even queen h5 still big trouble for
him but missing this move and then
missing the moves and then playing this
quiet move he's gonna have to go look at
his his folks and somebody on that team
is gonna say look it's okay it's okay
it's a
okay and let's say it a hundred thousand
times and we know he's been taking up
yoga he's gonna have to do some
meditation and get his mind right
because Magnus knows he dodged a bullet
today big time and maybe he's even
thinking while the guy's not ready for
it yet he's not ready to take my title
because it was on a silver platter for
me for him and he didn't do it so let's
hope that he rights the ship gets his
head straight because this match has
been one of those missed opportunities
so far what are we gonna see in game 9
I'm not even gonna try to guess because
it's been crazy but we'll be here to
call it as this match is getting more
and more tense and it's gonna be all
about like Peter like I said all about
the nerves that's right well I I think
Magnus today after being under big
pressure he did youdid defend and that's
what we're finding again and again one
slip and the other guy plays perfectly
it's a hang in there a big shout out
thank you very much to Peter Lee Co for
coming on our show and sharing with us
his specialty the special a cop had
happened to be perfectly time to have
such a guest and really he was marvelous
so big shout out thank you very much
Peter for joining us hope you do it some
more
thank you all for joining us and sharing
your day with us we will be back the day
after tomorrow we'll be back on
Wednesday that's the day before
Thanksgiving big travel day big party
night that's right and big chest day for
HS lovers as we're gonna see round 9 of
the world chess championship
[Music]
you
[Music]